FOR THE INTEREST OF TIME WE ARE
GOING TO GET STARTED. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO OUR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FOR TODAY'S HEARING IS TAKING
PLACE IN ROOM ELEVEN HUNDRED IN
THE NEW BUILDING. WILL BE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING THIS
HEARING. ONLINE THE PHONE NUMBER
IS TOLL FREE. 877-692-8957 THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO. ONE ONE ZERO ZERO IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE. AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE A WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING
PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS OF FOUR AD
ASM DOT CA DODGY OVIH. FOR OUR
IN PERSON PANELIST WELCOME. IN
THE NEW SPACE PLEASE PRESS THE
MIKE BUTTON. TO TURN ON YOUR
AUDIO ON AND AGAIN TO TURN IT
OFF THE LIGHT- INDICATOR WILL
LET YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE MIKE IS
ON OR OFF. WE HAD A LITTLE BIT
OF TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WITH
THE MICROPHONE TO FORCE OF JUST
MAKING SURE THAT FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT ARE TESTIFYING IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL NEW SPACE FOR THE
FIRST TIME. THAT YOU KNOW HOW
AND WITH THAT- LET'S DO ROLL
CALL PLEASE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRY OUT HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. GREAT
WILL BEGIN ON THE VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR WE HAVE JUST FIFTY FOUR
ITEMS FOR CONSIDERATION WHICH
ARE LISTED ON THE AGENDA FOR
YOUR REFERENCE WE WILL HAVE
THREE MOTIONS FOR THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. THE FIRST MOTION IS ON
THE FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY ISSUES.
AT ONE THROUGH ELEVEN FIFTEEN
THROUGH SEVENTEEN NINETEEN
THROUGH TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
THROUGH FORTY TO FORTY SIX
THROUGH FIFTY ONE OF FIFTY THREE
AND FIFTY FOUR CHAIR RECOMMENDS
ADOPTING ADOPTING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS CAN I GET A
MOTION. OKAY THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND WAS TO THE
ROLL CALL PLEASE. YEP FOR YOUR
AYE COOPER. LACKEY LACKEY I'D
NAZARIAN. WICKS WICKS NIGHT.
THANK YOU THE SECOND MOTION IS
ON THE FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY
ISSUES TWELVE THROUGH FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE THROUGH FIFTY TWO
CHAIR RECOMMENDS ADOPTING THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS CAN I GET
A MOTION. I'M SORRY TWENTY FIVE
AND FIFTY TWO NOT THROUGH FIFTY
TWO MY APOLOGIES. AT THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO MOVE
FORWARD CAN I GET A THANK YOU
MISS WICKS'S ARE SECOND. YEAH I
GUESS I CAN THANK YOU MR LACKEY.
AB CAN I GET A ROLL CALL PLEASE
THE AREA I COOPER. LACKEY LACKEY
NOW NAZARIAN. WICKS WICKS I.
THANK YO THE FINAL MOTION IS ON
VOTE ONLY ISSUES EIGHTEEN FORTY
THREE THROUGH FORTY FIVE JERICA
DOUBLING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS CAN I GET A
MOTION. THANK YOU MISTER LACKING
BY ROLL CALL PLACE AREA HI HI
COOPER. LACKEY MAKING A VOTING
NAZARIAN. WICKS WICKS I THANK
YOU AND WE WILL NOW BEGIN WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. GRANTS TO
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES
VICTIMIZED BY RETAIL THEFT
TODAY'S PANELISTS INCLUDE BRIAN
RUTLEDGE WITH- GOBIZ CAROLINE
GRAY DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE SIR BRIAN WHETHER FORD
WITH E. LA- AND TIM WEBER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. LET'S
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
CHAIR CARILLO ON MAY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ARE TERRIBLE
AND GRAY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE.
I THANK YOU FOR LETTING US. WALK
COMMITTEE THROUGH THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESS RETAIL THEFT CRAP
PROGRAM. I WILL KEEP MY REMARKS
BRIEF OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE
COMMITTEES TIME AND THAT WILL
BEGAN BY RESTATING OUR GOAL. WE
DESIGNERS- THIS PROGRAM TO
RECOGNIZE AND RESPOND TO THE
REAL IMPACTS THAT RETAIL HALF IS
HAVING ON SMALL BUSINESSES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE HERE- WE
INTRODUCED THE CONCEPT IN
JANUARY AND SINCE THEN WE'VE
BEEN WORKING TO DESIGN A PROGRAM
THAT STRIKES A REASONABLE
BALANCE BETWEEN EQUITY AND
EFFICIENCY. AND TODAY WE'RE
EXCITED TO DISCUSS OUR PLANS ARE
FLUSHED OUT PROPOSAL. BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED A
FRAMEWORK THAT DOES JUST THAT
WE'VE STRUCK A REASONABLE
BALANCE BETWEEN EQUITY AND
EFFICIENCY AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO GETTING THIS
COMMITTEES FEEDBACK. I'M I WILL
ALSO OFFER A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT- PLEASE NOTE THAT WE
DESIGNED THIS PROGRAM TO LOOK A
LOT LIKE HELLO SBA'S KOBE
NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT PROGRAMS
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE TARGETED
SMALL BUSINESSES BY BREAKING
THEM INTO THREE BUCKETS BASED ON
THE ANNUAL GROSS REVENUES. ARE
THAT'S HOW WE STRUCTURED THE
COVERT RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM AND
THAT'S THE STRUCTURE THAT WE'VE
FOUND TO BE ADMINISTRATIVELY IN
FACT DEATH WITH THAT IN MIND LET
ME EXPLAIN AT A HIGH LEVEL HOW
THE PROGRAM WILL BURKE. IF.
WHILE BUSINESS SIX IS RETAIL
STAFF ON OR JANUARY WE ARE ONE
TWENTY TWENTY. VACANCY MY RELIEF
YOU THIS. THEY WILL BE ELIGIBLE
IF THEY MEET THE- THAT YOU SEE
IN YOUR AGENDA. THERE IS A SITE
FIREMEN YOU HAVE TO BE A
REGISTERED BUSINESS OR NONPROFIT
WITH ANNUAL GROSS REVENUE
BETWEEN. FIVE THOUSAND AND FIVE
MILLION. THERE'S A CRIME
REQUIREMENTS YOU HAVE TO HAVE
EXPERIENCED RETAIL THEFT ON YOUR
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY ON JANUARY
ONE OR LATER AND YOU HAVE OUR
THROUGH FROM A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY REPORT OR ANY INSURANCE
CLAIM THAT YOU HAVE EXPERIENCED
RETAIL THAT. THERE IS THAT AND
OPERATING REQUIREMENTS AS WELL
YOU HAVE TO BE OPEN OR HAVE
PLANS TO BE OPEN. AND THE
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENT IS
THAT YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE STATE
TAX RETURNS AND OTHER DOCUMENTS
FOR VALIDATION PURPOSE SAYS. ARE
THE FINAL RESULTS IS THAT
APPLICANTS WHO ARE FACING RETAIL
FACT- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE UNEXPECTED
OPERATIONAL AND FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES AND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
SUPPORT ON THOSE WILL BE- ABLE
TO RECEIVE A GRANT THAT WILL
COME IN ONE OF. MOUNTS FIVE
THOUSAND THAT FOR THOSE WITH
ANNUAL GROSS REVENUE I'M BETWEEN. FIVE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR GRANT IF THAT REVENUE IS
BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
ONE MILLION. LASTLY A TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT IF
THAT REVENUE IS BETWEEN ONE
MILLION AND FIVE MILLION SO I
WILL STOP HERE AND I KNOW THAT
COBIZ AND CALLOUS CALLOW STA ARE
OPEN TO QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO JUST TO FOLLOW THE
PANEL IS- MISERABLE AGE. ARE YOU
PRESENTING LACKS SOME HAVE KOBUS
. THAT WAS OUR PRESENTATION ON
BEHALF OF THIS OF REDLANDS
BUDGET OFFICER OKAY WE'LL GO
THROUGH- THE ONLY A PLACE. BRAND
WHETHER POURED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EXPRESSED
GOAL FOR THIS PROPOSED NEW GRANT
PROGRAM IS TO PROVIDE.
COMPENSATION TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF
RETAIL THEFT. AND AS WE NOTED IN
FEBRUARY IMPLEMENTING THIS
CONCEPT WOULD FACE A LOT OF
PRACTICAL CHALLENGES AND- AT
THAT TIME WE HIGHLIGHTED IN
PARTICULAR HOW IT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT TO DEFINE THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND HOW
BEST TO DOCUMENT LOSSES THAT
BUSINESS OWNERS EXPERIENCE
RETAIL THEFT AND- AFTER
REVIEWING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND MEETING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IT WAS
CLEAR THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS GRAPPLED WITH THESE
CHALLENGES AND HAVE THOUGHTFULLY
ATTEMPTED TO BALANCE THE
PROGRAM'S REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
IN CONFLICT IS UNDETERMINED GRAY
HAD JUST. OUTLINED FOR YOU SO
FOR EXAMPLE THE PROGRAM WILL
NEED TO REQUIRE DOCUMENTATION OF
A CRIM TO REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF FRAUD WHILE ALSO BEING
FLEXIBLE AND SIMPLE ENOUGH TO
MINIMIZE THE BURDEN ON
APPLICANTS. NONETHELESS WE KNOW
THAT THE DEFINITION OF RETAIL
THEFT AND THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA ARE BOTH QUITE BROAD.
AND THIS RAISES TWO MAJOR
CONCERNS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
. FIRST WE BELIEVE THE PROGRAM
WILL BE QUICKLY OVERSUBSCRIBED
AND SECOND IT SEEMS LIKELY THAT
THE PROGRAM MAY NOT PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THE BUSINESSES
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE IN MIND AS
INTENDED. SOME OF THE TWENTY
MILLION THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED FOR THIS PROGRAM-
IN DOLLARS WOULD BE RESERVED FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES LEAVING
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
GRANTS. SO WE DID SOME MATH AND
THAT'S AT AN AVERAGE GRANT
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE PROGRAM WOULD
AWARD FEWER THAN ONE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED GRANTS. SO GIVEN THE
BROAD ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA WE
WOULD EXPECT THE PROGRAM WOULD
BECOME QUICKLY OVERSUBSCRIBED.
HOWEVER WE SHOULD NOTE THAT
NEITHER WE- NOR THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS CONDUCTED AN
ANALYSIS OF THE NUMBER OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE VICTIMS OF
THEFT ARSON AND VANDALISM. SO WE
DON'T KNOW FOR SURE EXACTLY WHAT
THE DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM WILL
BE. AND WHEN I SAY SMALL
BUSINESSES I MEAN THAT GENERALLY
BECAUSE IT WOULD APPEAR THAT
ALMOST ANY OTHER ANY BUSINESS
NOT JUST RETAILERS IT'S A VICTIM
OF PROPERTY DAMAGE. OR THEFT-
ARSON OR VANDALISM WOULD LIKELY
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS GRANT. AND
SO RETAILERS THE ONLY COMPRISE.
MORE PORTION OF THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE ABLE TO SECURE GRANT
BEFORE FUNDING IS EXHAUSTED.
GIVEN THESE POTENTIAL OUTCOMES
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT BY
CREATING THIS PROGRAM YOU COULD
FIND YOURSELF IN A SITUATION
WHERE DOWN THE ROAD- SIMILARLY
TO THE SMALL BUSINESS PROVE IT
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM. WHERE
MULTIPLE ADDITIONAL ROUNDS OF
FUNDING ARE REQUIRED TO MEET THE
DEMANDS. OF LESLIE WERE
CONCERNED THAT THE PROGRAM IS
RELATIVELY EXPENSIVE SIMILAR
PROGRAMS HAVE COSTS OF ONLY
AROUND 5% RELATIVE TO THE 15%
SET ASIDE FOR THIS PROGRAM.
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES POSED BY
SETTING UP A NEW COMPLICATED
PROGRAM THIS 50% OF THE TWENTY
MILLION MAY NOT BEYOND
REASONABLE AT ALL. BUT IT DOES-
AND FORMER ASSESSMENT OF ITS
LIKELY COST EFFECTIVENESS- GIVEN
OUR PRIOR- ESTIMATION OF THE
AMOUNT OF GRANTS THAT WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS PROGRAM THAT
WORKS OUT TO OVER TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES PER
GRANT. YOU WANT TO CONCLUDE BY
REITERATING OUR OVERARCHING
GUIDANCE THAT WE PROVIDED IN
FEBRUARY. THE YOU CONSIDER
WHETHER THE GOAL OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH YOUR
BROADER PUBLIC SAFETY. OR
PERHAPS IN THIS CASE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PRIORITIES. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS THANK YOU
. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BY TEN WEBER DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I MANY COMMENTS JUST
SAYING JUST TO SAY THAT- PUBLIC
I REMAIN SOMETHING
ADMINISTRATION IS CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IS INTENDED
TO HELP SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
SUFFERED THE EFFECTS OF THE.
THANK YOU I ACTUALLY AND THANKS
FOR THE PRESENTATION HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS. WITH THE RETAIL THEFT
PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED SIMILARLY
TO THE SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS
FROM LAST YEAR MEANING WILL A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTER THE
GRANTS OR WILL GO THIS. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. SO AS AS
THE DIRECTOR GRAY MENTIONED THIS
IS EXPRESSLY WE USE THE COVERED
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM AS A MODEL.
THE BUCKETS OF MAKING SO ANNUAL
GROSS REVENUE PUTS DIFFERENT
SMALL BUSINESSES BY SIZE AND-
CATEGORY AND THEN GET A GRANT
BASED ON THAT. THAT'S WHERE THAT
STRUCTURE CAME FROM THE SAME
THING FOR IMPLEMENTATION. SO WE
WOULD DO A COMPETITIVE BIDDING
PROCESS- WE'VE NOW HAVE MORE
EXPERIENCE THAN WE EVEN DID TWO
YEARS AGO SO WE'RE CONFIDENT.
THAT THERE ARE- PROVIDERS OUT
THERE THAT COULD HELP US WITH
THIS- AT THE SO BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCE WE SEE THIS WORKING
THROUGH THAT MODEL. AND IF I'M
JUST A FOLLOW UP TO THAT HOW
MANY GRANTS ONE OUT RECORDED
RELIEF. DIRECTOR GRADE DO YOU
HAVE THE LATEST AYE AYE IT'S
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS- SO I'M
NOT SURE DIRECTOR GRAY HAS HAS A
OFF THE TOP OF HER HEAD- A ROUGH
START. EDS ARE LASTER REPORT HAD. THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN. GRATZ I'M
SORRY ONE MORE TIME HOW MANY.
YES. THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
FRANCE AND I CANNOT HOLD STAFF
DID TO SEE WHETHER I CAN GET IT
MORE ACCURATE A NUMBER OF BUT
THAT IS WHAT WE DID IN OUR LAST
REPORT. SO ACCORDING TO THE L.
A. O. THIS THIS WOULD ACTUALLY
JUST AWARD ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED
GRAMS. THAT'S CORRECT THE SIZE
AS THE L. A. O. NOTED WELL
THAT'S TO- TO REINSTATE WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER WEATHERFORD DID
SAY BOTH OURSELVES IN THE ALLEY-
DON'T HAVE A VERY PRECISE VISION
OF WHAT THE FIRST LOOK LIKE. WE
WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT THAT
ESTIMATE IS BROADLY ON TRACK SO
HOUSE AND- OR MORE. SO IN
MAGNITUDE IT'S DIFFERENT- BUT
AGAIN. AS AS HE ALSO BROUGHT UP
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IS A
DIFFERENT STRUCTURE TO WHAT WE
ORIGINALLY DID WITH THE CODE
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM THAT'S
BECAUSE THIS IS ESSENTIALLY- TO
ADDRESS A PROBLEM THAT'S THAT'S
MORE COMPLEX ADMINISTRATIVELY.
THAN THE COVERED RELIEF GRANT
WHICH WAS MORE BROAD BASED THIS
IS A SPECIFIC IMPACT THAT
BUSINESSES WOULD. WOULD HAVE SO
IT'S NOT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF BUSINESSES THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTED- SO WILL WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THE POINT- THAT
THERE'S A MAGNITUDE DIFFERENCE.
SO WITH THERE SEEMS TO BE
AGREEMENT THAT PERHAPS A TWELVE
HUNDRED OF HUNDRED BUSINESSES
THAT WOULD BENEFIT. SEEMS TO BE
AN APPROPRIATE NUMBER SO HOW DID
CODE BIS. PROGRAM TO DETERMINE
THE TWENTY MILLION WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE SIZE OF THE PROGRAM
. THANK YOU FOR THAT THE TWELVE
HUNDRED- THAT IS THAT'S NOT
WHERE WE A MATCH AND WE DON'T
HAVE A PRECISE. VISION WE THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY THE MINIMUM THAT
WOULD WOULD BENEFIT. THE
ESTIMATE WAS BASED ON ONE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES IN OTHER
ADMINISTRATIONS. ONE OF THE BIG
THEMES AS FISCAL RESILIENCY-
WE'RE TRYING TO. BALANCE THE
TRADE OFF OF THE TO REAL NEED
OUT THERE. WITH WHAT CAN WE DO
BILL AND SO THERE'S VARIOUS
APPROACHES. TO WE THINK THIS IS
A REASONABLE APPROACH WE THINK.
WITH GRANT AMOUNTS OF THIS SIZE.
WE WOULD HAVE SOME LEGITIMATE
SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL BENEFIT TO
THOSE. WE WOULD KEEP THEM
OPERATIONALLY AND FINANCIALLY
AFLOAT- WHEN THEY'RE AT RISK OF.
OF BEING- YOU KNOW CLOSING THEIR
DOORS AND POTENTIALLY NOT COMING
BACK FROM THIS SO THAT WAS THE
UNDERLYING GOAL HERE- WE- USE
OUR BEST ESTIMATE FOR TWENTY
MILLION ESSENTIALLY. WELL LET'S
DIVE DEEP ARE A LITTLE BIT INTO
FISCAL RESILIENCY IN FUNDING
BENEFITS. WHERE THE GRANTS
AWARDED BY THE SIZE OF THE
BUSINESS VERSUS THE AMOUNT OF ON
COVERED LOSSES TO THE BUSINESS
FOR EXAMPLE A BUSINESS THAT MADE
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ON THEIR
LAST TAX RETURN BUT HAD A RETAIL
THEFT FIVE THOUSAND. UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL IT WOULD BE AWARDED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
A GROUND FORCES THE FIVE
THOUSAND IN THE RETAIL THEFT.
THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMPLEXITY THERE
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO MATCH THE
AVAILABLE STATE RESOURCES WITH.
ME THAT A BUSINESS SIX. WE HAVE
TALKED L. L. ABOUT THAT AND- AS
AS MR WHETHER NOTED WE GRAPPLE
WITH THAT OVER THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS AND FROM OUR VIEW WHERE
LAND HERE. THIS THE ONE WAY TO
DO THIS PROGRAM YOU OFFER
EVERYONE THE SAME FLAT AMOUNT OF
RELIEF. THAT WOULD BE
INEQUITABLE IN OUR VIEW- THE
OTHER THING YOU COULD DO IS YOU
COULD TRY TO DETAIL THE DOLLAR
BY DOLLAR AMOUNT OF A- OF A
REVENUE IMPACT THEIR BUSINESS
EXPERIENCES. FROM OUR VIEW
THAT'S ADMINISTRATIVELY
UNREALISTIC AND GETS MORE
COMPLEX AND EXPENSIVE- SO. WE
TRIED TO. BALANCE THAT AND WHERE
WE LANDED WAS THIS WAY BY USING
ANNUAL GROSS REVENUE AS THE
DEFINING THE BUCKETS AND THEN
ALSO DEFINING. FREE FIXED GRANT
AMOUNTS THAT SIMPLIFIES FOR BOTH
OURSELVES AS THE ADMINISTRATORS
THAT ALSO SIMPLIFIES INTERVIEW
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESSES WHO. IT
CAN BE DIFFICULT TO DOCUMENT
YOUR DOLLAR BY DOLLAR IMPACT- SO
THIS IS BASICALLY A ATTEMPT TO
BALANCE. YEAH I'D YOU KNOW I'M
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING WHY WE WOULD USE
TAX DOLLARS ARE PUBLIC DOLLARS
TO AWARD SOMEONE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHEN THEY ONLY
HAD FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH
OF. RETAIL THEFT I'M NOT SURE.
THAT THE MATH ADDS UP. I'LL JUST
MAKE ONE MORE POINT WHICH IS-
AND I WOULD TAKE WITH KNOWLEDGE
THAT CONCERNED. WOULD SAY THAT
IN THIS LANGUAGE WHAT WE'VE DONE
TO MITIGATE THAT IS REQUIRED
THAT. THE ONLY USE THAT A
GRANTEE CAN MAKE OF THESE
DOLLARS. IS TOWARDS OF. A AN
EXPENSE THAT WAS NOT COVERED BY
AN EXISTING INSURANCE CLAIMS. SO
ESSENTIALLY IF YOU'RE A LARGE
BUSINESS IN THE EXAMPLE YOU
GAVE- THEY'VE ALREADY. IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD IF THEY'RE ON THE
LARGER- THE HIGHER SCALE THESE
ANNUAL REVENUES. THEY PROBABLY
HAVE INSURANCE AND THEY PROBABLY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SORT OF
MAXIMIZE THEIR INSURANCE CLAIM.
AND SO THIS WOULD SUPPORT THEM-
AND SORT OF FILL IN A GAP ON
POTENTIALLY REVENUE LOSS FROM
CLOSED DOORS OF THAT SORTOF
THING. SO WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
BUT WOULD WE'VE DONE OUR OUR- WE
OFFERED WHAT WE THINK IS A
REASONABLE APPROACH TO MITIGATE
. IS IN THE INTENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES THOUGH YOU JUST
TALKED ABOUT LARGE BUSINESSES.
I'LL CLARIFY THAT THAT'S IN THE
SCALE OF THE THREE REVENUE
BUCKETS I MEANT THE EXAMPLE YOU
GAVE WAS FROM WHAT IF A
BUSINESS. THAT'S A YOU KNOW
THREE MILLION ANNUAL REVENUE
THAT BUSINESS IS LARGER THAN.
THE BUSINESS WITH A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. BUT IN THE GRAND
SCHEME OF CALIFORNIA. THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY THAT'S CAN
STILL BE A SMALL BUSINESS- IT'S
BROADLY SIMILAR TO THE COVERED
RELIEF GRANT IN THAT WAY IN
TERMS OF THRESHOLD OKAY AS I'VE
I DID SAY ONE MILLION NOT THREE
BUT THAT'S OKAY I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO CONVEY. I
DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS
BUT I DO WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IF THEY
WOULD LIKE TO ASK ANYTHING ELSE.
I WANTED TO- JUST ASK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT OUTRAGE SO IS IT A
FIRST COME FIRST SERVED SURFERS
ARE SERVE BASIS WILL THE OUT
REACH FOR THE PROGRAM- BE OPEN
AHEAD OF TIME HOW WILL WE ENSURE
THAT THE FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED
ON AN EQUITABLE BASIS. RESHOOT
THAT THAT QUESTION THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE GRAPPLED
WITH AND- AS THE DRESS DIRECTOR
GRAY MENTIONED THIS IS OUR
EFFICIENCY HERE WHERE. IF WE
START TO ADD FILTERS ON WHO'S
ELIGIBLE AND WE TRY TO SAY LET'S
PRIORITIZE ACTS BY GEOGRAPHY WHY
BY- SOME DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. THE
PROBLEM IS FOR BOTH THE SMALL
BUSINESS THAT CREATES AN ADDED
BURDEN OF TRYING TO JUMP THROUGH
THE HOOP AND PROVE THAT YOU FALL
INTO THAT. AND ALSO FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION PERSPECTIVE OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS IT ADDS A
COMPLEXITY THERE- SO WE ARE
TRYING TO. GET THIS ON A FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE BASIS BECAUSE
WE'RE THINKING- IT'S MORE
EQUITABLE OR IT'S AN EQUITABLE
GOAL TO GET THE FUNDING OUT
QUICKER. KNOWING THAT IF YOU ARE
BUSINESS WITH HUNDRED K. ANNUAL
REVENUE. AND GET THE SCRIPT AT-
THE DIFFERENCE IN A MONTH OF
GETTING IT WHICH THIS WHICH TO
DIFFERENT WAYS OF A- DEFINING
ELIGIBILITY MIGHT SLOW DOWN-
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THAT'S IT'S
WORTH THAT. SO WE SHARE THE
CONCERN ABOUT EQUITY AND THIS IS
OUR ABILITY TO TRY TO THREAD
THAT NEEDLE. IT HAS BEEN THE
EXPERIENCE OF THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE LAST TWO YEARSAMID COVE IT
AND CALL IT RECOVERY EFFORTS FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT. ITS
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES A BUSINESSES
WHERE IS. WHOSE FIRST LANGUAGE
IS NOT ENGLISH- HAVE HAD. 
THE BEST RESULTS IN TERMS OF ONE
RECEIVING FUNDING RECEIVING
RESOURCES HAVING ACCESS TO
RESOURCES. SO WHAT IS WHAT IS
THE- I GUESS OUT REACH APPROACH
AND HOW YOU ARE GOING TO. HELP
THOSE MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
IF IT'S ONLY ON A FIRST COME
FIRST SERVE BASIS WHERE IT'S
THOSE THAT ARE MOST SAVVY. THAT
WILL HAVE ACCESS. FREESHIP THAT
POINT AS WELL. THE IT AS A
DIRECTOR GREAT CAN YOU CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THE HOW THE CODE RELIEF
GRANT OUT REACH WORKS AND HOW
THAT'S A MODEL THAT WE WOULD
USE. ABSOLUTELY I THANK YOU I'M
SURE COULD BE- THAT IN-
RECOGNIZING THE CONCERN FOR OUT
REACH- THAT ARE UNDERSERVED
BUSINESSES. WE WOULD DEFINITELY
FOLLOW THE MODEL WHICH FRANKLY
WE ARE PERFECTING. ARE FROM IT
STARTED WITH THE COVERED RELIEF
GRANT- PROGRAM BUT FRANKLY WE
HAVE MODELED THAT OUTREACH IN
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS NOW. AND
IT'S PRETTY MUCH- STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURE FOR STANDING
UP A PROGRAM. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE- PARTNERS THAT ARE
PROVIDING OUTREACH. ON THE END
ENGAGEMENT ARE IN LANGUAGE AND
MAKING SURE THAT I'D- WE CAST
THAT NET. AS FAR AND AS WIDE AS
WE POSSIBLY CAN. OUR PARKERSBURG
. RIGHT BUSINESSES IN MORE THAN
THIRTY LANGUAGES AND WE WOULD
HAVE THIS EXPECTATION. OF OUR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
AND ECOSYSTEM TO SUPPORT THIS
PROGRAM. IN THE EXACT SAME
MANNER. THANK YOU DIRECTOR GRAY
JUST AT ONE POINT WHICH IS THAT
IN THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE WE DID
SPECIFY THAT A CALLOW IS BA AND
THE THIRD PARTY PROVIDER WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO. CONDUCT
EXPENSES- EXPECTS BANDS OF. AN
EXTENSIVE OUTREACH- BAKER DON
ESSENTIALLY THE COVER GRANDMA
ALSO AS DIRECTOR GRAY WAS
MENTIONING WE'VE WE HAVE A MODEL
THAT WE THINK IT'S EFFECTIVE FOR
MAKING SURE. FOLKS THAT THE NEED
EXTRA AWARENESS FOR ASSISTANCE-
CAN GET THAT. THANK YOU I WANNA
ASK MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IF
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS MISTER LUCKY
. YES A. L. I FIRST OF ALL WANT
TO SAY THE ENORMITY OF THIS
PROBLEM AS THE- IS. AND I'M
THANKFUL LEASE WERE DRESSING IT
IN SOME MANNER AT THIS TIME AND
I'M THANKFUL THAT WERE. AT LEAST
RECOGNIZING IT BUT- I HAVE A
VERY INTERESTING QUESTION WHY.
WHY IS ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
PENAL CODE FOR NINETY POINT FOR
NOT INCLUDED. WE HAVE NINE OTHER
STATUTES THAT ARE INCLUDED- THIS
IS A STANDALONE CRIME. A FOUR
NINETY POINT FOUR IS NOT AN
ENHANCEMENT SO SHOULD BE
INCLUDED- THE OMISSION OF THIS
CRIME HIGHLIGHTS OF THE LANGUAGE
AS PROPOSAL LIKELY CREATE MORE
CONFUSION. AN ACTUAL BUREAUCRACY
THAN GETTING MONEY TO THOSE
AFFECTED BY CRIME. PRESHEAF THE
QUESTION AND THE ADMINISTRATION
IS HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON MAKING SURE THIS
IS SUCCESSFUL- THAT SOUNDS LIKE
IT COULD BE A REALLY HELPFUL
CONTRIBUTION IF WE INCLUDED IT
SELL OUT HAPPY TO. THE LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE INPUT THANK YOU
FOR THAT. THANK YOU MISTER LUCKY
AND WON- JUST FINAL QUESTION FOR
ME IS THIS GRANT ONLY OPEN FOR A
RETAILER OR FOR ALL SMALL
BUSINESSES THERE'S A BROKEN
WINDOW UNDER THE LANGUAGE
QUALIFY AS RETAIL THEFT. THANK
YOU SO WE DIDN'T DEFINE THIS AS
A RETAILER SPECIFIC WE COULD
HAVE USED THE NEXT CODE FOR
EXAMPLE TO MAKE IT RESTRICTED TO
CERTAIN RETAIL BUSINESSES BUT
OUR GOAL HERE IS TO ADD TO
MITIGATE A CERTAIN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY IT'S NOT TO SUPPORT
SPECIFIC TYPE OF BUSINESS. SO
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE IN MIND NOT
JUST A CLOTHING STORE SOMETHING
SELLS COMMODITIES THERE COULD BE
ACROSS THE STREET FROM THAT SAME
BUSINESS- BUSINESS SERVICES FIRM
THAT- EXPERIENCES A SIMILAR TALE
CRAP- WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WAS INCLUSIVE AND AVAILABLE TO
SORT OF A THE IN RATHER THAN.
NEXTCODE L. TYPE A BILL.
SELFRIDGE A REST WHO HAS THEIR
WINDOWS BROKEN AND THEIR CHAINS
BROKEN IN THEY'RE REGISTER
STOLEN AND THERE. TABLES AND
CHAIRS STOLEN WOULD QUALIFY. AS
AS WRITTEN THAT IS THAT IS IT
WOULD DEPEND ON A COUPLE FACTORS
AS WRITTEN BUT ESSENTIALLY YES-
THE IDEA IS THAT. IT'S ALSO KEY
TO NOTE THAT AS WRITTEN WE HAVE
IT SO INSURANCE OUR EXISTING
INSURANCE CLAIMS WOULD WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE USES OF THE FUNDING
SO IF YOU'RE A RESTAURANT YOU
HAD INSURANCE. AND LET'S SAY
INSURANCE COVERED YOU FOR THE
BROKEN WINDOW- THEN THAT
WOULDN'T BE AN ELIGIBLE EXPENSE
BUT WHAT BE THE SHIRLEY TURNS
DOESN'T COVER YOU. HAVE TODAY AT
THE CLOSE THAT ONE SO YOU CAN
GET SOME SORT OF SOME FROM THE
STATE HERE AFTER THAT LOST
REVENUE THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
IMPACTFUL. THAT IT THANK YOU.
THERE AREN'T MORE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THANK YOU SO
MUCH GENTLEMEN AND THANK YOU
DIRECTOR. SHE IS. FROM YOUR YOUR
CAR HOPE YOU'RE AND- THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA GO ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO SALES AND USE OF TAX
EXCLUSION. AND JUST IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'M JUST GOING
TO ASK THE PANELISTS TO
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
PLEASE BEGIN. MAKE SURE YOUR
MIKE IS ON. OKAY THANK YOU I
DIDN'T KNOW SAID IN MY REMARKS
YOU DID I WAS SO CAUGHT UP IN
THE PREVIOUS THAT PRESENTATION.
I DEREK TURNOUT EXECUTIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
AND ADVANCED TRANSPORTATION
FINANCING AUTHORITY.
AFFECTIONATELY ARE UNOFFICIALLY
KNOWN AS KEEPER. AND WE ARE HERE
- REQUESTING ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OF THE FOR TWO NEW POSITIONS TO
CARRY OUT INCREASED WORKLOAD IN
OUR SALES AND USETAX EXCLUSION
PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM IS
SUPPORTED BY APPLICATION
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AND THERE IS
NO IMPACT TO THE GENERAL FUND.
AND APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU L. L. OR WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. BUDGET OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MATTHEW
ASPECT OF ARMINA FINANCE WE HAVE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS EITHER.
IF THERE ARE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. OF
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT
THE SPRING FINANCE LETTERS ARE
MOTION. I WILL SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE. YEP I COOPER COOPER II
LACKEY LACKEY I NAZARIAN. WICKS
WEBSITE. THANK YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW WE COULD KEEP ALL THE PANEL
IS JUST MOVING FORWARD I THANK
YOU SO MUCH I'M GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. ENFORCEMENT
OF MISSIONS ENHANCEMENTS
CONCILIATION SENHANCE MEANT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT'S CHAIRMAN
AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MIKE MILLER I AM D.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING OUR FIRST PROPOSAL
RESOURCES TO DECREASE WAIT TIMES
FOR INVESTIGATIVE APPOINTMENTS.
BRITAIN'S SINCE AND SETTLEMENTS
WITH OUR ENFORCEMENT OF. RELATED
TO BOTH EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
COMPLAINTS HISTORICALLY THE
TYPICAL AVERAGE WAIT TIME
BETWEEN THE INTAKE OF A
COMPLAINT IN THE INVESTIGATIVE
INTERVIEWS APPROXIMATELY THREE
MONTHS. LAST YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
EXPERIENCED A SURGE IN
COMPLAINTS THAT INCREASE THE
WAIT TIMES BEEN EMPLOYMENT FROM
THREE MONTHS TO FORM IT'S AN
HOUSING FROM THREE MONTHS TO SIX
MONTHS. WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
CAN INCREASE SUBSTANTIALLY DUE
TO THE RECOVERY OF THE LABOR
MARKET AND WITH IMPENDING
REACHED A VERY STATE LOCAL AND
FEDERAL EXPLORATORIUM'S DESIGNED
TO PROTECT TENANTS DURING COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WAIT TIMES IN
BOTH ND HOUSING HAVE DECREASED
AGAIN TO APPROXIMATELY THREE
MONTHS OVERALL. THROUGH THE USE
OF OUT OF CLASSES CITING ITS
STRATEGIC OVERTIME AND
RECRUITMENT OF RETIRED
ANNUITANTS. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOW US TO DO. WE TIME FROM
THREE MONTHS TO ONE MONTH AND
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CASES OUR
INVESTIGATORS ARE ABLE TO
CONCILIATE OR SUBTLE. JAMIE
TODAY'S MERRY WEEK DLPH CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU L. A. O.
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS NOTICED MORE HONEST WITH
THE L. A. O. WE HAVE NO ISSUES
TO RAISE ON THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS MORALIS
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. ENTER MARCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FOR THE
COMING YEAR MIKE WAS A NON.
HELLO OKAY ANJA MARX DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENT.
THANK YOU JUST ONE QUESTION FOR
ME BEFORE I PASS IT ON TO OUR
COMMITTEE DOES THE P. E. H. PLAN
TO ADDRESS VACANCY ISSUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT. WE DO STOP ALSO OVER
THE COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC- WE
LIKE MANY DEPARTMENTS WERE NOT
IMMUNE TO THE GREAT RESIGNATION.
OUR ENFORCEMENT VACANCY RATE
RIGHT NOW STANDS AT THIRTEEN
PERCENT. WE'VE DONE SEVERAL
THINGS OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS TO HELP REDUCE THE
VACANCY RATE WE'VE INSTITUTED
CONTINUOUS JOB POSTINGS FOR OUR
INVESTIGATOR POSITIONS IN BOTH
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. WE PULL
APPLICATIONS ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS OUR FIRST WAS JANUARY
FIFTEENTH AND WE HOPE LEVIN
PEOPLE ARE SECOND CUT OFF JUST
OCCURRED APRIL IFTEENTH TWO
WEEKS AGO AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WILL FILL OUR REMAINING
INVESTIGATOR VACANCIES IN THE
COMING MONTH. AND WE ADVERTISE
AND TRY TO RECRUIT FOR MULTIPLE
PLATFORMS BESIDES JUST COLLEGE
ARE ON OUR OWN WEBSITE WE'RE
POSTING ALL OF OUR POSITIONS ON
LINKEDIN THROUGH RECRUITER. AND
WE'RE ADVERTISING OPENINGS THE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
SIMPLICITY WITH. OF UP GREATER
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS RECEIVED
. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS- YES MISTER COOPER I
HAVE WILSHIRE I THINK THE REALLY
THE BIGGEST ISSUE IS THE PAY FOR
THE STATE SUCKS SO WHILE YOU
WORK FOR THE STATE. REFER LOOK
MUNICIPALITY POLICE OR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT MAKE MORE MONEY AND
THEN TO ME IF YOU'RE
INVESTIGATOR FOR THE STATE WITH
YOUR IT IT EASY D. OR OR OR
WELFARE FRAUD OR- CANNABIS OR
WHOEVER CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO THE
SAME PACE SKILL WHERE EVERY
OTHER ORGANIZATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA HAS THAT EXCEPT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO CAN YOU
DRESS THAT IT AND THEN ALSO GEN
RE HOW MANY FOLKS ARE WALKING
OUT THE DOOR AND GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE. I URGE. RATE HAS. BEEN
THAT DRAMATIC OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS IF. WE DID HAVE A
SPIKE EARLY ON IN THE PANDEMIC.
WE WERE VERY QUICK TO ADOPT
HEALTH WORK. ON THAT I THINK
THAT HELPED QUITE A BIT- IN
RETAINING OUR PEOPLE BUT I THINK
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME IS AS
PEOPLE REALIZE THEY COULD DO.
ALMOST ANY JOB FROM ANYWHERE-
THIS IS A TOUGH JOB IT'S NOT
EASY AND WE DO HAVE PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
DECADES WE HAVE SOME OF THE JOB
. TO AGO SO. VERY ROBUST
TRAINING PROGRAM- TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. BUT WE
FREQUENTLY DEAL WITH PEOPLE ON
THE WORST DAYS OF THEIR LIVES
THEY LOST THEIR JOBS. THEY'VE
BEEN DISCRIMINATED OR HARASSED
THE LOSS THE ROUTINE YOU'RE
LOSING THEIR HOME. SO WE HAVE A
LOT OF TOOLS TO HELP OUR
INVESTIGATORS- YOU KNOW MAINTAIN
THEIR SENSE OF BALANCE. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I PROTECT PERSON TO
ADDRESS THE RATE OF STATE HEY
THAT MIGHT BE A QUESTION PAPER
DIRECTLY CAN ONLY CHART- WE ARE
RESTRICTED BY STATE
CLASSIFICATIONS SO WE CAN ONLY
GO BY THE MIN AND MAX OF THOSE-
BUT WE DO DO OUR BEST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH ABILITY
PROGRAM- THEY WERE ABLE TO
TRANSFER PEOPLE FROM- YOU KNOW.
THIS TO SPECIALIST AND EVEN
SUPERVISORS. YEAH I THOUGHT. YES
MY- BY ON THE CAN FOR YOU NOW.
AND THE PAY. I SAID IT VARIES I
MEAN INVESTIGATORS INVESTIGATOR.
YOU CALL THE SAME BACKGROUND AND
TRAINING. BUT IT'S ALL OVER THE
PLACE OR SIDE LETTERS FOR A LOT
OF FOLKS. THAT VERY DIFFERENTLY
AND THAT'S THE REALITY I GUESS
SAID. YOU CAN MAKE MORE IT COULD
C. H. P. TENS. A RESEARCHER
DEPARTMENT THEN THEY MAKE IN
THESE POSITIONS IT REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY. AND IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN ISSUE WITH HIRING
AND GETTING FOLKS TO COME IN.
FOR SOME FOLKS WILL COME IN AND
GET THEIR TRAINING THEN LEAVE.
THE STATE GO SOMEWHERE ELSE ONCE
ONCE THEY'VE ACQUIRED THE
KNOWLEDGE AND TRAINING FLIGHTS.
IT'S BEEN A CONTINUAL ISSUE SO-
I'D I'D BE CURIOUS ABOUT THAT IN
AN ALSO. KELLY CHARGE PAR THE
PROBLEM. IF BESIDE- WITH EVENING
LOOK AT THE COW FOR INSTANCE.
OKAY SURPLUS. IF YOU'RE A
CERTAIN CLASSIFICATION. THERE'S
A PAY SCALE FOR THAT. NO MATTER
WHAT YOU ARE. IN OF YOUR
GOODWILL HERE WHETHER YOUR
INVESTIGATOR FOR THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. THE UBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IT'S THE SAME
PAY SCALE IS NOT THAT WAY AND TO
ME WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE THAT
OTHERWISE. YOU CONTINUE TO GET
FOLKS THAT LOOK AT ESPECIALLY
NOW. THE SHOP AROUND WHOSE PAY
IS MORE LUCRATIVE. AND I'M HERE
TO TELL YOU IS NOT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S THAT'S A
REALITY. THANK YOU NUMBER HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER KNOW
WHAT IT IS R. ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON FROM MR MILLER ON
THE. HAVE I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OKAY
WELL WITH THAT SAID THE-
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS ARE
MOTION. THANK YOU ROLL CALL
PLEASE AREA I THREE I COOPER
COOPER I'D LACKEY. MIKEY OF
STAYING THERE IN. WICKS WICKS I. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR I T. WORKLOAD LET'S
BEGIN. SOURCE SECOND PROPOSAL-
INCLUDES THREE POSITIONS FOR OUR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SERVICES
DIVISION TO SUPPORT MULTIPLE
EFFORTS INCLUDING PAY DATA
REPORTING AND ENFORCEMENT UNDER
SB NINE SEVENTY THREE OUR ONLINE
CUSTOMER SERVICE SUPPORT SYSTEM
STATEWIDE TELEWORK SUPPORT AND
TO ADDRESS MULTIPLE PRIVACY AND
SECURITY FINDINGS FOLLOWED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY. AND THE COP
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
AND AGAIN CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
MERRY WE USE HERE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO THE L. A. O. PLACE.
THE DALLAS WITH THE L. A. O. NO
ISSUES RAISED ON THIS PROPOSAL
EITHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- AND YOU ARE
STRUGGLING TO FINANCE NO FURTHER
COMMENT ON THIS FOR. THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS ON THE DICE. SEEN
ON THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
ADOPT THE SPRING FINANCE LETTERS
ARE MOTION. THANK YOU ROLL CALL
PLEASE AREA I AREA I COOPER.
COOPER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY I KNOW
THEY'RE IN WICKS WICKS I. THANK
YOU WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT
MITIGATION PROGRAM LET'S BEGIN.
HI EVERYONE ZACKS ARE BURKE IS.
YEAR THANK YOU FOR R. L. BACK.
WHAT ARE. BEING HELD IN. BUT YOU
SIX NINE FIVE IF THOUSAND
DOLLARS BUT PHARMACY ON SEED
SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU I'M JUST
ASK THESE SPEAK A LITTLE TO YOUR
MIGHT YOU SAW A LITTLE FOR AWAY
OR IF WE AND- TECH TO. PUT HIS
MICHAEL HI PLEASE. THANK YOU.
THE OTHER MUCH BETTER YES OKAY
THANK- YOU CAN BE IN REQUEST
FIFTY MILLION SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
THIS AND- POINT POINT THREE. SB
FIVE THOUSAND. FOR GOING TO NEED
OVER YOU THIS YOU CAN OTHER THE
DALLAS LOCKER. FOR
UNLIKE OR DAMAGE TO AND LOSS OF
PROPERTY. AND WHILE I. AND YOU
PROGRAM FOR BOTH IPHONE FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THIS REQUEST NOT
A- FUNDING OP ED RETHINKING
LETTERS. AFTER WHICH MEANS THAT
ROCK PARTS ARE. THANK YOU L. NO
MORE NO LESS ALIONA ISSUES WITH
THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. ENTER MERGED
BERMAN A FINANCE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU JUST A COUPLE
COMMENTS FROM ME A QUESTIONS
WHAT DOES THE WHEN DOES A HCD
ANTICIPATE HAVING THIS PROGRAM
UP AND RUNNING. SO ARE WE ALL
THE BIRDS YOU CAN GAP. ACROSS
THE PEOPLE GOING ALL IN FOR HIM
. GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD FOR US TO
BE DIRECTOR FOR A DIVISION OF
FEDERAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING THROUGH THE
ANNUAL ACTION PLAN PROCESS-
WHICH IS A REQUIREMENT BEFORE WE
CAN ACTUALLY BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT
THE FUNDS FROM HIGH. SO WE
ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO HAVE
SINCE MADE THAT IN THE NEXT
SIXTY DAYS OR SO. AND TAKES
ROUGHLY ANOTHER NINETY TO A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS TO HEAR BACK
FROM FROM OUTSIDE AND THEN WE
CAN BEGIN THE PROCESS TO
IMPLEMENT SO OUR GOAL IS TO BE.
WOULD BE ABLE TO UP WITH THESE
FUNDS OUT- IN AN ALLOCATION
FORMATS- TOWARDS THE END OF THIS
YEAR AND THE BEGINNING OF NEXT
YEAR. THANK YOU TO THE DIRECT
APPLICATION JURISDICTIONS
ALREADY RECEIVED FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM. SINCE THIS IS- A NEWER-
PROGRAM AND WE ARE ABLE TO START
TO LINK IT UP WITH SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS THAT ARE
ALREADY RECEIVING FUNDING- WILL
BE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DIRECT RECIPIENTS TEND TO BE.
WHAT IS THE BEST WAY TO DEPLOY
HOW BEST TO COORDINATE. THANK
YOU ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ENSINANDO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
ADOPT THE SPRING FINANCE LETTERS
ARE MOTION. THERE'S SECOND OKAY
THANK YOU ROLL CALL PLEASE AREA
HI I COOPER COOPER AYE LACKEY
LACKEY AYE NAZARIAN WICKS WICKS
I. THANK YOU WERE GOING TO MOVE
ONTO ISSUE NUMBER SIX HOME
INVESTMENT PARTNERSHIPS PROGRAM
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. LET'S
BEGIN. CAN WE GET MR SACK ON
SCENE ON THE LINE. SORRY I WAS
SPEAKING WITH ME AT ALL I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT MAN. OF COURSE
IT'S ONLY BEEN A TWO YEAR
MICROPHONE YEAH WELL MY
MICROPHONE PROBLEMS. WE CAN HEAR
YOU BETTER- EASY IT'S REQUESTING
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR LONG EVEN IF
YOU HOURS AND- A ROW FIVE. BOTH
WITH. TWO BILLION OUT OF TWENTY
ONE FOR A WHILE THE DEVELOPMENT
THIS BURKE THE NEW FUNDED MORE
EVENT PARTNERS PROGRAM. IT'S
ALSO COMPANY BY FOR TO OFFERED
LET I THOUGHT OR THAT HOPE.
ENTER OUR REFUSED PROGRAM. WE
ARE NOT FEDERAL THAT BROUGHT THE
BY SEVERAL WITH. INCLUDING FOR
THE AND BY LOCAL. MANY OF THE
CONFLICT WITH IT ALLOW HER WOULD
BE.
I WANTED PROFIT THAT COMPANY.
IT'S QUITE IMPORTANT FOR THE
WORKING WITH THE WHITE. OUR
CURRENT WE NEED OUTRAGE ON ALL
ACTION FROM THAT- OVERALL THE
PUBLIC. HI YES RIGHT CLICK YOUR
OUR PROFITS FREE ONE WHAT IN
RESPONSE ABOUT OFFERING BOB IT
REALLY LIMITS ABILITY TO IN
FEDERAL. OFTEN HAPPENS- AND THAT
WHENEVER YOU GET. ONCE WELL. AS
AFTER THE A WALK BUT- YES YES
CLIP IN. ARE AT HOME ARE YOU
HIGH. OF ALL OF THE HOME GROWN.
WE ARE WORKING BUT WITH THE WITH
OF OUR. RIGHT AROUND. IF THE
FUNDS ARE. MAXIMIZE JEFF
ROBINSON OF. THANK YOU L. A. NO
MORE WITH THE A. M. THE
QUESTIONS IN THE FOR ADVICE
GROUP IMPLEMENTATION OF ARE WE
WITH OF THOSE BUT NO WE DON'T
HAVE SORT OF COMMENTS RAISE OUR
THIS RECALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- ENTER MARC
BERMAN FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD.
THANK YOU JUST A QUESTION FROM
ON MY END HOW THE NEW FEDERAL
HOME PROGRAM INTERACT WITH THE
STATE'S HOME KIAN EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM. I CLIP
WE NEED AN ANSWER THAT WILL THAT
WILL BE A LIBRARY I'M BETTING
YOUR SINS ARE VERY SIMILAR TO A
LOT. MORE OF THAT. I DIDN'T-
ONCE WE ARE ABLE WELL. THE FUNDS
- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR I
ACTUALLY INCREASE THE- CARD
HOLDER WHAT YOU IS THAT. USES IN
THE BALLPARK. PROGRAM SO OFTEN
LET LET JEFF LIBRARY THAT THE
GREAT TEACHER PROGRAM FOR LOW.
VERY SIMILAR AND YOU THINK. LIKE
WHAT YOU WANT MANY FORCING OF-
FEDERAL ANTI FUN PURPOSES SO
ECONOMY. EFFORTS AND IN SOME
WAYS IT MAKES A LOT EASIER TO
FIND A LOT OF. NOT TO LOOK
HAVING TO MAKE. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL ARE FOR MISTER LUCKY
. JUST REAL QUICKLY WHAT A
FINISH ARE BEING TAKEN ENSURE
RURAL SOME JURIST. ARE GOING TO
BE GETTING ANY OF THIS- FUNDING. YEAH MOST OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT EACH YEAR HE IS FOR THE
OFFICE WE HONOR. RURAL DISTRICT
SO WE WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH
HYPERTEXT. YEAH ACTUALLY PLAY.
CHARLES AND CONTACT. WELL ARE WE
IF YOU GROUP AT THE FIRST
PROVIDERS MAKES THE SMALL. WITH
A BUNCH ONE MONTH I ON LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS BUT WITH A LOT
OF DOLLARS SMALLER. BOTH IN-
REALLY WELL FIVE FIVE MINUTES
HOUSING FOR INCREASE FOR
BASICALLY INVOLVES MISTER ALMOST
SEEM WE'RE HAVING A TO. TIME HE
YOU SO IF YOU MIND REWINDING
YOURSELF LIKE SIX SO. AND I'VE
ALWAYS. YEAH ONE OKAY I'M NOT
YOUR GOING ON- SO BASICALLY WAS
SAYING OFFER SECOND LOOK AT THE
BLACK. WE OFFER CONTRACT. MANY-
WITH. I WAS SAYING BE SMALL.
HAVEN'T WHITE BOX BACK WITH. YOU
ARE. THANK THEM. YEAH REQUIRING
A OF- A LOT OF FUN WITH FIVE
DOLLARS AFTER. YEAH WE GOT- I
LOVE WHAT I DO BEGINNING LIKE AS
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE WE ARE
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE NON. OPEN
THE SMALL. WHERE WE ACTUALLY
SPEND MOST OF OUR- WHAT WE CARE
ABOUT GOVERNMENTS. THANK ROTH ON
LOOKING FOR A FREE. JUST
ELABORATE REALLY QUICKLY- AS-
THE VIGIL SEEMS ARE SAYING THAT
THE PRIMARY- ROLE OF THESE FUNDS
ARE TO GO TO NON ENTITLEMENTS
WHICH IS COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
FIFTY THOUSAND IN OPULATION OR
LESS SO THAT REALLY IS OUR
SUBURBAN AND RURAL. COMMUNITIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND SO
THAT IS THE PRIMARY BENEFICIARY
FOR THESE BONDS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. THE
RECOMMENDATION IF THERE ARE NO
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN. TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS. AS FROM C. THANK
YOU AND HOPEFULLY I HOPE YOU CAN
HEAR ME WELL THIS HAS TO
REQUEST- TACKY ATTACHED TO IT
ITS REQUEST THE REAPPROPRIATION
OF TEN MILLION FOR THE
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY PILOT
PROGRAM THOSE INCLUDING THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE BUDGET ACT
IN THE EXTENSION OF A
LIQUIDATION DAY FOR THE CLEANING
GRANT PROGRAM TWENTY. EIGHTEEN
YOUR THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO DECEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE IN ORDER TO ALIGN WITH
EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE THAT PASSED
IN TWENTY TWENTY. THE FIRST PART
OF THAT PREPARATION IS BASED ON
GOVERNOR DAYTON'S PROPOSAL
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO INVEST IN
MORE ADAPTIVE REUSE WE RECOMMEND
HOLDING THE TEN MILLION INTO
THAT AFTER FOUR MINUTES IN THE
FIFTIES. AND THE LIQUIDATION
DATE EXTENSION IS TO CONFORM THE
EXPENDITURE DEADLINES PASSED SB
TWO CLEANING- PROGRAM WITH THE
SUBSEQUENT CLAIM GRANT
INVESTMENTS THE STATE MADE.
PROGRAMS A REIMBURSABLE PROGRAM
AND THE JORDY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE INDICATED THEY
ARE TARGETING THEIR WORK BASED
ON THAT THE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE. AS INDICATING AGENDA- TO
GIVE A LITTLE MORE BACKGROUND
THEY'RE ONLY FIFTEEN OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED METER DIFFERENCE THAT
RECEIVED THE GRANT FUNDS HAVE
FULLY CLOSED OUT THE. GRANT NO.
MANY OF OUR AND OF. IN ORDER TO
THOUGHT AT. THANK YOU I DON'T
KNOW WHAT MAGIC YOU DID BOTH CAN
NOW HEAR YOU A REALLY GREAT SO
MUCH APPRECIATED LET'S GO TO THE
L. L. PLACE. THIS MORALES WITH
THE L. A. O. NO ISSUES TO RAISE
ON THIS ITEM THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ENTER
MARCH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING THAT. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEM NONE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH- ENCAMPMENT RESOLUTION
GRANTS. GOOD AFTERNOON ADVENTURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO COME BEFORE YOU
AGAIN I'M VICTOR ON I'M DIAGRAM
MR DONE I'M GONNA JUST INTERRUPT
YOU FOR A MOMENT WE'RE HAVING A
HARD TIME HEARING YOU YOU SOUND
VERY LOW. MAYBE A TRY AGAIN.
THIS COUNT FROM ONE TO FIVE AND
WE CAN TELL YOU IF WE CAN HEAR
YOU BETTER. ONE TWO. THREE FOUR
MUCH MUCH BETTER WE JUST NEED
YOU TO STAY AT THAT LEVEL. OUR
GREAT WE CAN ALSO INCREASES
MICROPHONE MAYBE. THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
MANAGER- AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU AGAIN I'M
VICTOR ON I'M THE GRANT STRECKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS
HOUSED UNDER THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY- SO THANK FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
REQUEST FOR A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION AND
ACCOMPANYING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CHANGES TO PROVIDE
LOCAL ENTITIES WITH GRANTS IN
SUPPORT OF PERMANENT HOUSING
SOLUTIONS FOR CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS. AND TO ALSO
SUPPORT RESOLVING ENCAMPMENTS
SITES ACROSS THE STATE AS ALL OF
YOU KNOW THIS REQUEST BUILDS ON
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME PAYMENT RESOLUTION PROGRAM
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR AND WHICH- OR- IN
THIS FIRST ITERATION OF THE- WE
RECEIVE REQUIRE FOR ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
PROGRAMS IN DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF OUR NEIGHBORS LIVING IN
ENCAMPMENTS SO MORE THAN TWICE
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION THAT WE HAD
AVAILABLE. IN ADDITION MANY OF
THE JURISDICTIONS THAT REACHED
OUT TO US EXPRESSED THAT THEY
WOULD ACTUALLY SUBMITTED
MULTIPLE PROPOSALS TO RESOLVE
MULTIPLE ENCAMPMENTS ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITY IF MORE FUNDING HAD
BEEN AVAILABLE- IN ADDITION. THE
NEED FOR A MUCH LARGER SCALE
PROGRAM IS REFLECTED IN THE MOST
RECENT POINT IN TIME COUNT OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WHICH REFLECTED THAT TWO THIRDS
OF CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE UNSHELTERED
THAT'S OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND THE HIGHEST RATE IN
THE NATION. THIS REQUEST WILL
ALLOW US TO FURTHER INVEST IN
FLEXIBLE INNOVATIVE AND TARGETED
IN CAMPAIGN RESOLUTION
STRATEGIES BUT TO DO SO AT THE
SKATE. C. THAT'S NEED. SOLVING
ISSUE I'M SO WITHOUT I WELCOME
YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU LOL.
MELISSA LEO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSED AUGMENTATION THE
NEW KEVIN RECOGNITION PROGRAM IS
MANY ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE ABOVE
WHAT WAS PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED
FOR THE PROGRAM AT THE TIME WE
RELEASED FOR JANUARY BUDGET VERY
LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT HOW THE
ORIGINAL FIFTY MILLION
AUGMENTATION WAS BEING USED AS A
RESULT WE COULD NOT ASSESS THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE PROGRAM SINCE
THEN THE PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION
EXCUSE ME HAD ANNOUNCED. THE
AWARD OF THE ORIGINAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE ALSO
SUGGESTED THE LOGISTICS THE
TICKET AND DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN ASSESSING THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE PROGRAM
BEFORE ANY DECISIONS ARE MADE
ABOUT ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTATION
THAT SUCH THE QUESTIONS REASON
THE. AGENDA ARE APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU. AS A PART OF FINANCE
PLEASE. RIDLEY THOMAS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
. ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS CAN A CALLOUS
CH EXPLAINED THE PROCESS OF HOW
GRANTS WERE AWARDED FOR THIS
PROGRAM. ABSOLUTELY SO UNLIKE
OUR OTHER GRANTS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE MINISTER WHICH
ARE AWARDED ON A FORMULA BLOCK
PROCESS THAT IS PROPORTIONALLY
ALLOCATED BASED ON POPULATION OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN ELIGIBLE COMMUNITIES THIS WAS
A COMPETITIVE BE AWARDED
CORRECT- AND ANOTHER KEY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS GRANT
AND PRIVATE CALLAS YOU. IT IS
THIS COMES OPEN TO CITY OF ANY
SIZE IN ADDITION TO COUNTIES
CONTINUE OF THAT CARE AND THE
LARGEST CITIES- SO AS
COMPETITIVELY- ADMINISTER
GRANTS. EACH PROPOSAL WAS SCORED
INDIVIDUALLY BY A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM OF EVALUATORS
USING CRITERIA THAT WAS OUTLAWED
IT THE PUBLIC. OKAY DESCRIBE ARE
BETTER CALLS THAT HELLO IN
ADVANCE OF THE MINDS OF- SOME OF
THESE ELEMENTS THINGS THE
GRANTEES COME AND EXPERT- THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THE ENCAMPMENT
THAT WAS GOING TO BE SERVED-
MODEL- FIRST WORDS SERVICE. AND
OF GREAT CONCERN IS HEALTH
WELLNESS AND PERSON CENTERED
APPROACH TO SERVING THE PEOPLE-
IN THE PROPOSAL- AND RECOGNIZING
THE VERY LIMITED RESOURCES THAT
WERE AVAILABLE- THERE WAS AN EYE
TOWARDS INTIMIDATION BECAUSE OF
COURSE THIS FIRST ITERATION OF
THE IN CABIN GRANT WAS INTENDED
TO BE- FOR PILOT PROJECTS. SO
THAT WE CAN FIND SOME OF THOSE
BEST PRACTICES THAT COULD
EVENTUALLY BE SCALED UP OR DOWN
FOR COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. ANOTHER CONSIDERATION IN
AWARDING THESE GRANTS IS THAT
STATUE DID REQUIRED TO THE
EXTENT FEASIBLE THE STATE
AWARDED GRANTS IN A MANNER THAT
RIGHT. THE DIVERSITY OF UNITY
PROCESS STATE SO AND FOR THAT
ALL TYPES OF COMMUNITIES ACROSS
ALL OF CALIFORNIA HI ACCESS.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE DETAILS AS
TO WHO I'M LOOKING AT THE
NUMBERS AND THE CITIES THAT
WERE. AWARDED FOR EXAMPLE CITY
OF FRESNO WAS AWARDED FIVE
MILLION TO RE HOUSE ONE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS. WILD SALMON MEDINA
COUNTY WAS AWARDED ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION TO HOUSE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY INDIVIDUALS. WHAT'S
THE COST DIFFERENCE. SO THERE'S
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT CONTRIBUTED TO WHY SOME-
GRANTS WERE AWARDED BASED ON THE
COST DIFFERENCE- YOU KNOW THERE
WAS NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL SORT OF
MODEL AND THAT'S WHY A ON THIS
WAS COMPETITIVELY- THIS WAS
COMPETITIVELY ADMINISTRATOR
INSTEAD OF USING SOME KIND OF
RATTA YOU KNOW FUNDING FOR
PERSONS SERVING SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT CONTRIBUTED TO THE
DIFFERENCE. SIR ARE. WORD BRING
. THE BUSES OF THE MODEL THAT
WAS GOING TO BE FUNDED DIRECTLY
BY THE PROGRAM THERE WERE SOME
INSTANCES WHERE THESE FUNDS AND
THE PROPOSAL WERE ESSENTIALLY
SEED MONEY. AND THAT WAS IN A
COMMUNITY THAT HAD ROBUST
EXISTING RESOURCES AND
PARTNERSHIPS THAT COULD BE
LEVERAGED AND THESE FLEXIBLE
FUNDING SOURCES WOULD HELP-
BREAK FUNDING GAPS AND
ACCELERATE- EFFORTS- THERE ARE
SOME COMMUNITIES AS YOU'RE ALL
AWARE THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
FEWER RESOURCES AND SO THEY WERE
MUCH MORE. RELY SOLELY ON THESE
. TO PROVIDE THE START TO FINISH
WITH WRAPAROUND NEEDS AND SO THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A COMMUNITY
WHERE. A WHERE IN THESE THESE
DOLLARS WERE JUST NEEDED TO DO
THE INITIAL OUTREACH OR TO DO
THE SHOW INFRASTRUCTURE. YOU
MIGHT HAVE A MUCH LOWER PERSON
LAST THEN ON. WHERE MAY NOT BE
AS MANY EXIST. LOCAL RESOURCE
LEVERAGE AND WORDS DOLLARS HAD
TO PROVIDE MOST ASPECTS OF. THE
SERVICE DELIVERY. THANK YOU I
GUESS I OWE FOR UP WITH YOU AND
WITH STAFF I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT. WHAT THOSE DIFFERENCES
WERE AS TO WHO EXACTLY HAD SEED
MONEY VERSUS. A EXISTING
PROGRAMS BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WOULD THOSE DETAILS WILL HELP US
DETERMINE. WHERE ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES CAN GO WHAT WORKS WHAT
DOESN'T AND- I'M- NOT
NECESSARILY TRYING TO REINVENT
THE WHEEL BUT CERTAINLY TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT. HOW WE PUT MORE
RESOURCES INTO COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT
WORK- I WANT TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THAT RECEIVED A GRANT
FOR ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION. TO
RE HOUSE SIX C. INDIVIDUALS AND
MAYBE DO A COMPARISON OF WHAT
OTHER TYPE OF AWARDS THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES HAS RECEIVED I ONLY
BRING IT UP NOT ONLY BECAUSE I
REPRESENT THE CITY OF LA BUT
BECAUSE SKID ROW WAS IN OUR
BACKYARD. SKID ROW IS THE
LARGEST HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT
CENTER COMMUNITY IN THE NATION
AND SO TO SEE. OF YOU KNOW A
GRANT TO ONE POINT SEVEN TO ONLY
RE HOUSE SIXTY. I'M JUST CURIOUS
AS TO. WHAT PLANS ARE BEING
DEVELOPED TO HELP THE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MANAGER THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND OF COURSE WE SHARE
YOUR CONCERN WITH RESPECT TO-
YOU KNOW LOS ANGELES IS ONE OF
THE EPICENTERS OF THIS CRISIS.
OF COURSE THAT. LARGE PART BY
PUTTING. FORWARD BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE YES THE
INITIAL ABOUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS CANCER PORT PILOT
PROJECTS THAT COULD EVENTUALLY
BE STUDIED AND SCALED UP AS YOU
ALLUDED TO- THERE'S URGENCY AND
A SCOPE OF THE CRISIS THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS IT. WE ARE OF
COURSE POLICE ISN'T. A SENSE. NO
FUNDING POSTED. L. RIGHT FUNDING
THIS I'M AS I IN MY PREVIOUS-
THIS PROGRAM WAS COMPETITIVE BID
RATHER THAN BET ON A
PROPORTIONAL FORMULA SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN OUR HEALTH PROGRAMS-
A LITTLE OVER 40% OF THE TOTAL
ALLOCATION STATEWIDE
APPLICATION- TO. WRECK IT. IT
COMMUNITY- AND I HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE- LOS
ANGELES- YOU KNOW HOUSING
SERVICES AUTHORITY UP THERE
PROPOSAL THAT THEY SUBMITTED AND
THIS PROGRAM AS DESIGNED- WOULD
PUT THEM AT THE FRONT OF THE
LINE TO RECEIVE FUNDING. AS SOON
AS YOU'RE OUT. NAME OF A LOCAL-
YOU KNOW AND I WOULD ALSO. THAT
A TWO OF THE NINETEEN AWARDS-
WERE IN L. A. COUNTY LONG CITY
OF LONG BEACH AND CITY OF LA AND
HEY WERE AMONGST OUR HIGHEST
COURT APPLICANTS. I NEED TO WORK
WITH THAT- AND POTENTIALLY SCARE
BOB POSITIONAL FUNDS ARE
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE IN A VERY
INTERESTING SPACE WHERE WE HAVE
TO RAMP UP QUICKLY AND URGENTLY
. BUT ALSO. AND WHAT DOESN'T SO
THEY WERE JUST YOU KNOW PUTTING
MORE MONEY OUT THERE ARE NOT
SEEN THE RESULTS THAT MANY OF
OUR YOU KNOW CONSTITUENTS WANT
TO SEE IN TERMS OF- RESOLVING
THIS MAN'S IMMENSE- TO THAT
WE'RE ALL FACING. A IF THERE ARE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HOLD- THIS ITEM OPEN FOR THE
MOMENT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ONTO IS
FOR NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU LEGAL WORKLOAD WITH. BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JEANNIE HERMAN CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER OF FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ISSUE NINE RELATES TO OF GB'S
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
REQUESTING RESOURCES OF FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AN ONGOING TO FUND
SIXTEEN NEW PERMANENT POSITIONS
- UPGRADE POSITIONS. ASSOCIATED
WITH ADDITIONAL COMPLEXITIES OF
WORK. AS WELL AS AN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO TAKE CARE OF SALARIES
THAT ARE TYPICALLY UNFUNDED IN
OUR DEPARTMENT FOR THE LEGAL
STUFF. FTV ATTORNEYS I'M- USING
UP TO BE ATTORNEY GENERALLY- WE
DO. SUFFER FROM A HIGH RETENTION
RATE OF THE THAT LOOSELY- WITH
OUR STUFF AND THEY CAN ACTUALLY
BE QUITE COSTLY AND COMPARED TO
HOW THEY ARE FUNDED AT THE FIRST
AND THE MID STOP OF THE PAY
SCALE RANGE AND THEY ARE
TYPICALLY MORE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE TOP LEVEL OF STOCKS SO WHILE
WE ENJOY. THEIR BENEFITS AND
THEIR EXTREME KNOWLEDGE OF THAT
THEY BRING TO OUR ORGANIZATION
AND ASSISTANCE TO TAXPAYERS FROM
A BUDGET PERSPECTIVE THEY CAN
PROVE GREAT CHALLENGES SO WE ARE
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AUGMENTATION AS A RESULT. WITH
THESE RESOURCES HAVE TO BE WILL
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE NEW
WORKLOADS THAT ARE PRESENTING AS
A RESULT OF THE APPEAL PROCESS
AT THE OFFICE OF TAX APPEAL BUT
IT'S GOING WELL. ENSURE STOP OR
THE APPROPRIATE CLASSIFICATION
LEVEL TO DO THE WORK THAT WE
NEED THEM TO DO. AND AGAIN THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO HIRE
EXPEDITIOUSLY WHEN WE HAVE
VACANCIES CURRENTLY WE ARE
HOLDING THOSE VACANCIES.
VACANCIES OPEN FOR A CERTAIN
PERIOD OF TIME TO ENSURE THAT WE
DO HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO
PAY OUR STAFF- BUT AS NOTED IN
THE AGENDA THE QUESTION WE WILL
BE ABLE TO HIRE MORE FREQUENTLY
WITH THIS ADDITIONAL. LEVEL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU MS HERMAN ALEJO PLACE. BRIAN
WHETHER FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DO NOT HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
APARNA FINANCE GOOD AFTERNOON
KRYSTLE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
AND NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS OR
COMMITTEE. OKAY SEEN ON THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS ARE
MOTION. THANK YOU ROLL CALL
PLEASE HURRY UP HI ARE YOU AYE
COOPER. COOPER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I NAZARIAN. WICKS WICKS
NIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
ISSUE NUMBER TEN THE VOLUNTEER
INCOME TAX ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TOO
LONG FRONT OF FOXSPORTS OF
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT DIRECTOR.
ISSUE TENNIS OF TV'S BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR THE
VOLUNTEER INCOME TAX ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS THE VITA
PROGRAM WHICH REQUIRES ONE POINT
TWO MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
EXTEND FIVE LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS ARE SET TO EXPIRE JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
BY ONE YEAR AND ALSO ALLOW FOR
THE REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE COST
THAT IS INCURRED BY THE
DEPARTMENT COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT OR
COUNTY IT SEQUENCE. THIS
RESOURCES WILL OUT OF TO BEAT MR
VITA OF EXPANDED LEVELS IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANT FUNDING THE
BEEN APPROPRIATED. FOR THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY. FISCAL YEAR.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE FREE TAX
PREPARATION AND TO EXPAND
MARKETING AND OUTREACH OF CAL E.
I. T. C. THESE RESOURCES PROVIDE
TRAINING TO INDIVIDUAL
VOLUNTEERS PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND PARTICIPATE IN
OUTREACH MEETINGS. THE FUNDING
IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT UP TO
BEACON SUPPORT THE INCREASED BY
THE SERVICES BEING PERFORMED BY
THIS OF THIS. PERFORMED ACROSS
THE STATE BY OF THE GRANTEES ARE
USING THE GRANT FUNDS. SB THREE
CLASSES FOR ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION BECAUSE THE
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE INCLUDES ONE TIME
PUBLISHED GRANT FUNDING. IF
CURRENT FUNDING IS EXTENDED OR
MADE ONGOING THAN FTP WOULD NEED
RESOURCES TO MATCH THE DURATION
OF THE GRANT FUNDING. IN THE
AGENDA THE QUESTION WAS ASKED AS
TO WHETHER OF TO BE WOULD NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IF
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH FUNDING IS
ADDED- AND YES OF TO BE WOULD
NEED THOSE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES-
IF CAUGHT CUT FUNDING IS
INCREASED. IN ORDER TO
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT TO GRANTEES
ARE PROVIDING THE SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU L. L. BRIAN WITH THE FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND- WE JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE EVALUATED
THE CAL E. I. T. C. OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION EFFORTS AND- AMONG OUR
COMMENTS WE SUGGESTED THAT YOU
MAY WANT TO. PRIORITIZE FUNDING
TO EXPAND AWARENESS OF OPEN
ACCESS TO THE FREESTATE FILING
OPTIONS SUCH AS CAL FIRE CAPT
CAL FINAL IS RECALL FILE AND THE
BUDGET PROGRAM- BUT HOWEVER WE
DO NOT HAVE A SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATION REGARDING THIS
PROPOSAL. IN CONSIDERING THE
MERITS OF THIS PROPOSAL- YOU MAY
WANT TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION A
LITTLE TAKE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW OFTEN. ARE
THE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE FREE TAX
PREPARATION ASSISTANCE SERVICES
ARE USED BY THE TARGET
POPULATION. OF FOR EXAMPLE ARE
THE STATE'S ALWAYS BUSY OR ARE
SOME SITES NOT ALWAYS HAVING A
LOT OF CLIENTS. AND IF THEY'RE
NOT ALWAYS BUSY YOU MIGHT ASK
WHAT ACTIONS THE ADMINISTRATION
COULD TAKE TO EXPAND THE
SERVICES AND- THANK. SYSTEM
THANK YOU THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
EXCELLENT QUESTIONS WONDERING IF
THOSE CAN BE ADDRESSED. SURE I
CAN ADDRESS- SOME COUPONS THAT
QUESTION SO IN TERMS OF THESE
SERVICES- FTP DOES HAVE THE
VITA- SITES AND ALSO THE BANNER
TO ADVERTISE- VITA SERVICES WILL
PROBABLY ON A WEBSITE. WE'VE
ALSO PARTNERED WITH THE GRANTEES
AS WELL SO THAT- ON OUR WEBSITE
IF A PERSON WAS SEEKING BY THE
SERVICES YOU CAN TYPE IN THE ZIP
CODE AND OUT. AND SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE NOT DAY AND ALSO IF
RELEVANT OR IF- THE BILL SITES
ALLOW FOR IT THE- PERSON WHO
SEEKING THE SERVICES CAN ALSO GO
IN TO MAKE AN APPOINTMENT SO
THAT THEY CAN ACCESS THE
SERVICES. THAT ARE NEEDED. IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO REALLY
EXPAND THE OUTREACH WE ARE
LOOKING AT A VARIETY OF OPTIONS-
IN ORDER TO REALLY INCREASE THE
UPTAKE. SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT
WE ARE EXPLORING IS WORKING
PARTNERING WITH US THAT ARE
STAKEHOLDERS AND ALSO WITH THE
GRANTEES HELLO. HOUSE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE ABLE TO UTILIZE THE
SERVICES TODAY. HOW ARE THEY
ACCESSING IT HOWARD THE OUT OF
IT SO WE CAN TRANSLATE THOSE
SUCCESS STORIES IN ORDER TO
REACH A WIDER AUDIENCE. THANK
YOU FROM THE FINANCE. BRAZIL
FINANCE- NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY HELP. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEN ON JUST ONE ON
MY END IS IT BETTER TO MAKE
THESE POSITIONS ON GOING OR FUND
AND FUND THEM FOR THREE YEARS OR
MORE OR KEEP THIS THESE
POSITIONS ON A- OF A ONE TIME
BASIS. I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SO. ON A ONE TIME BASIS
BECAUSE FOR THE IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET OF THE TEN MILLION
APPROPRIATION IS FOR ONE TIME
AND THESE RESOURCES ARE IN
DIRECT SUPPORT OF THAT
ADDITIONAL TRAINING. TWENTY SIX
CETERA IF THE GRANT FUNDING WAS
TO BE- EXTENDED OR OPENING A
THREE YEAR FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT
THEN WE WOULD REQUEST RESOURCES
FOR A MATCHING DURATION. GOT IT
THANK YOU. THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN BANKING
OPERATIONS ITEM PROCESSING SOFT
. MISTER GARTH THERE.
AS WE HAVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS ON ON DAVID TO WORK DAY
ON THE DIRECTOR OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. OF THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE REQUESTING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY AND
CORRESPONDING FUNNY FOR ONE TIME
COST OF SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND TO UPGRADE ITS
CHEN ON MISSION CRITICAL CHECK.
POINT SOFTWARE IN ONGOING COST
OF TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FOR INCREASED ANNUAL
SUPPORT COST FOR THE SOFTWARE.
ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR THE SOFTWARE USED BY S. TEO
WILL REACH ITS END OF LIFE AND
ACCORDINGLY THE VENDOR WILL-
ENDED SUPPORT. THUS IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THE SDO UPGRADES
THE CURRENT AND SUPPORT TO A
CURRENT INSUPPORTABLE VERSION TO
ENSURE THAT IT CAN CONTINUE TO
PERFORM ITS RESPONSIBILITIES OF
CASH MANAGEMENT WITHOUT
INTERRUPTIONS. I HAVE ANDREA.
OUR CENTRALIZED TREASURY AND
SECURITIES MANAGEMENT DIVISION
DIRECTOR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS A
YOU GUYS MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO THE L. L. PLACE. WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS THE PART OF
FINANCE- JIM DOYLE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE PULLED MANY INVESTMENTS
ACCOUNTS. A P. M. A. OPERATIONS
THANK YOU.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF MY NAME IS
KRISTEN TO CALLIE MORE I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF INVESTMENTS AT THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE AND
pOFFICE IS REQUESTING A FULL TIME
PERMANENT POSITION AT THE
ASSOCIATE TREASURY PROGRAM
OFFICER LEVEL TO SUPPORT
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF SECURITIES HELD BY THE
POOL OF MONEY INVESTMENT FOR.
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS. HAS
GROWN FROM APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
SEVEN BILLION TO TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX BILLION AS OF TODAY-
AS A RESULT THE NUMBER OF
SECURITIES TRANSACTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT INCREASE IN
IDLE CASH IN THE ACCOUNT HAS
GROWN SUBSTANTIALLY WE CURRENTLY
HAVE FIVE PERMANENT STAFF WHICH
INCLUDES TWO MANAGERS THAT
HANDLE THE SETTLEMENT OF THESE-
DAILY PURCHASES OF SECURITIES
FOR THE DIVISION- WHICH- ON ANY
DAY CAN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
IS INVESTED CAN RANGE ANYWHERE
FROM HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS TO.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THESE TASK CANDLE
BY THE STAFF MEMBERS BE DONE
WITH EXTREME CARE THIS INCLUDES
THE CALCULATING AND VERIFYING OF
INTEREST PRICES IN DISCOUNT AND
COST OF THE SECURITIES. AND THAT
INITIAL WORK ALSO HAS TO BE
COMPLETED UNDER VERY STRICT
DEADLINES- AS THOSE PURCHASES
AND THE CLAIM SCHEDULE SOCIAIS
DID WITH THEM NEED TO BE SENT TO
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE BY TEN
THIRTY EACH MORNING. AND THE
TRANSACTIONS. THIS FOR THE LIVER
OF THE SECURITIES- THE DIVISION
HAS MANAGED THE INCREASE IN.
MONIES IN THE ACCOUNT AS WELL AS
THE NUMBERS OF SECURITIES BY
HAVING MANAGERS. TAKE ON SOME OF
THE TASK OF ANALYTICAL DISEASE
SEEMED THAT WOULD NORMALLY BE
HANDLED BY STAFF MEMBERS AS WELL
AS WORKING WITH OUR I. T.
DIVISION TO STREAMLINED WORKLOAD
AND PROCESSES. WE'VE ALSO RELIED
SINCE LAST YEAR A TEMPORARY HELP
ON HELP ON HALF TIME BASIS. TO
OUR TO HANDLE SOME OF THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
INCREASED A NUMBER OF
INVESTMENTS AND WE'VE ALSO HAD
TO. DENY SOME STAFF TIME OFF.
WITH STAFF SOURCES ARE STILL IN.
WE'RE GREATLY CONCERNED
OBVIOUSLY OF THE POTENTIAL FOR
ANYTHING A CALCULATION ERROR
STAFF TURNOVER BURN OUT AND ALSO
AND MISTAKES THAT COULD COST THE
STATE- FUNDS. A IF. AND WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO HANDLE OPERATIONS
MORE EFFICIENTLY ALLOWING FOR
CROSS TRAINING AND BACK UP THE
EXISTING STAFF AND IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW MANAGERS TO RESUME DUTY
THAT THEY HAVE HAD TO PUSH ASIDE
INCLUDING AN IMPROVING THEIR
PORTFOLIO APPLICATION AS WELL AS
EXPANDING.
IF THANK YOU L. L. CURRENT
WEATHER FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DO NOT HAVE
A CONCERT TO RAISE WITH THIS
PROPOSAL DEPARTMENT FINANCE. JIM
DURABLE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
CONCERNS. MISTER MISTER LUCKY OF
QUESTIONS LITTLE HEAD I JUST
HAVE AN ASTOUNDING. THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT'S BEING- ENTRUSTED
. WITH SUCH A SMALL AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE IT IS HOPE THEIR DARN
GOOD MAN AND WHILE THAT'S THAT'S
YOUR SPOT EARLY IT IS EACH
RESPONSIBILITY AND WE HAVE VERY
DEDICATED STAFF VERY LOW
TURNOVER AND WE WOULD LIKE IT
THAT. A PERSON. IT'S A MUST SAYS
FORCE SERVICE WILL PROTECT IT
USE. THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER
LUCKY BECAUSE I WAS ACTUALLY
GONNA BE MY QUESTION TO YOU
WHETHER ONE STAFFER SUFFICIENT
TO HANDLE THE INVESTMENTS BEING
MADE YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION WE BELIEVE THAT- THE
ONE WOULD BE SUFFICIENT GIVEN
WHAT YOU'VE OBSERVED THE AT THE
- STAFF AND- SAN. GOING FORWARD
IT BUT WE THINK BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THAT THANK YOU FOR THAT
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ONTO ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN LABOR BRING FINANCE
LETTERS. THE MOBILE HERE CHOOSE
INCLUDING. INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S US BRING FINANCE
LETTERS RELATED TO THE LABOR
DEPARTMENT'S. LIST THE FIRST. IS
RELATED TO THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
TOGETHER THIS WITH THE
OPERATIONS THE INFORMATION
SECURITY PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
BRING LETTERS. BEGIN A PANEL. AT
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M J. STORE
ASSOCIATE SECRETARY FOR FISCAL
POLICY WITH THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TO YOU TODAY IT'S BEEN A LONG
AGENDA YOUR BUT YOUR STAFF A
DONE A GREAT JOB SUMMARY.
POSIBLE FOR YOU POST RUSSIAN IN
TWO POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING. MANAGE EXISTING AND NEW
WORKLOADSWITHIN LABOR AGENCY.
EIGHT OF THE REQUESTED POSITIONS
WOULD SUPPORT EXISTING WORKLOAD
THAT THE AGENCY. THE PROPOSAL
ALSO INCLUDES TWO NEW POSITIONS
A DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR CARE
POLICY AND AN ASSISTANT
SECRETARY FOR CLIMATE. IS TO NEW
POSITIONS WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE OVERSIGHT AND
ADVANCEMENT OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT REGGIE'S AND
POLICIES IN THE CURRENT CLIMATE
SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY. I MIGHT
BE CANCER. THE PHONE MANY HAS
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL. AND NOW
THE INFORMATION SECURITY PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS GEORGE OKAMOTO I AM
AGENCY INFORMATION OFFICER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR WORK FOR SOME
AGENCY RESPECTFULLY REQUEST BUT
SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIANS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA SIMPLY TO DEVELOP
A CABINET LEVEL AGENCIES CREE
PROGRAM THIS REQUESTING SIX
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. POSITIONS ESTABLISHED
PLAYER TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
WHICH WILL STOP THE RULES OF
AGENCY PRIVACY OFF. THIS AGAINST
SPECIAL. THIS FEELS A ABILITY
ALIGNMENT CAL PUB COLLEGES
TELSEY ROAD WHICH WAS DEVELOPED
BY THE STATES THAT ARE OF
INFORMATION SECURITY. IN A
PUBLIC IN A TWENTY ONE. THE
CASKET SERVER AVERSE MODEL IS
MULTI TO STRUCK THAT ENCOURAGES
COMMITTEE COORDINATION AMONGST.
LEADERS CABINET LEVEL AGENCIES
AND OR ENTITIES. WITH YOUR
APPROVAL SPEAKS LOUDLY IT'S EASY
TO. A IT SERVICE. IS PROCEED IN
FOR VICE AGENCY LEADERSHIP ON
CYBERSECURITY RISKS THREATS AND
INCIDENTS. ASSIST WITH
INFORMATION SECURITY RESOURCE
PRIORITIZATION AND REINFORCE THE
WHITE SERVICE PRETTY CULTURE.
APPROVING THESE POSITIONS WILL
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S SECURITY
POSTURE BY INSURING RISK IS
MANAGED FOR THE CRITIC PUBLIC
SERVICES TO PROVIDE ACROSS THIS
PORTFOLIO. THANK YOU I WOULD TO
THE L. L. BEFORE WE GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. JAZUSAMO
WITHOUT LET ANALYSTS OFFICE ODD
FOR NEITHER A PREDATOR OF THESE-
APRIL. LETTERS DO WE HAVE A
SPECIFIC COMMENTS ARE CONCERNED
BUT TO WORK WITH THAT THE
COMMITTEE OR STAFF OUGHT TO FALL
UP AS THE- YOU MUST MONTHS UNDER
PERMANENT. I'VE DONOVAN
APARTMENT IF NO FOR THE COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME IT HAPPENED ANYWAY
. THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM. THE COMMITTEE.
ENSINANDO IS ONE FOR ME OUT WITH
THESE REQUESTED POSITIONS THAT
THE AGENCY- DISSIPATE CONTINUING
THE PRACTICE OF RE DIRECT THE
STAFF FROM OTHER DEPARTMENT
SHOULD WORK OUT ISSUE PRICE. A
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION NOT
GOING FOR. I'VE BEEN. IN THE B.
C. B. S. AND WORKING WITH
LEGISLATURE- THESE BAR
REDIRECTED POSITIONS WERE DONE
MOSTLY MANY MANY YEARS AGO UNDER
PRIOR ADMINISTRATIONS SO IT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE LOOKING TO CLEAN
UP AND NOT GOING TO GO BASIS.
THANK YOU FOR. THE RECORD IS TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT A LABOR
ISSUE WHICH IS THE SOCIAL
ENTREPRENEURS FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT LIQUIDATION SPRING
LETTER. AGAIN THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN. GOOD AFTERNOON. THE
PURPOSE OF THE SOCIAL
ENTREPRENEURS FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CANADA FIRES I'M
SORRY AGENDAS ARE RICH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT MANAGER FOR
THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL.
THANK YOU. THE PURPOSE OF THE
SOCIAL ENTREPRENEURS FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVE
ALSO KNOWN AS SEED IS SUPPORT IS
TO SUPPORT THE ENTREPRENEURSHIP
OF EMMA. LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT INDIVIDUALS WHO FACE
SIGNIFICANT EMPLOYMENT BARRIERS
AS WELL AS INCREASE THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC DIVERSITY AND HELP SPUR
BUSINESS INNOVATION. THE SEAT
INITIATIVE PROVIDES MICRO GRANTS
ENTREPRENEURIAL TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SEE
TARGET POPULATIONS THE SUPPORT
THEM IN STARTING OR MAINTAINING
A SMALL BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
AIMED AT ADDRESSING A SOCIAL
PROBLEM OR MEETING A COMMUNITY
NEED. THIS IS DONE IN
PARTNERSHIP ET BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE A TRACK
RECORD OF CREATING AND
ADMINISTERING LINGUISTICALLY AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT PROGRAMS
FOR SEATS TARGET POPULATIONS.
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE C.
CONTRACT TERMS ARE CURRENTLY FOR
THIRTEEN MONTHS AND ARE SET TO
EXPIRE ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL HAS HEARD FROM A
NUMBER OF PROGRAM COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION PARTICIPANTS
THAT THE THIRTEEN MONTH TERM
FROM JUNE FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TO JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. IS INSUFFICIENT TIME
TO GET THIS NEW PROGRAM UP AND
RUNNING. PROVIDE QUALITY
OUTCOMES IN ORGANIZATIONAL
CAPACITY BUILDING. THERE IS NO
STATUTE MANDATING A SPECIFIC
TERM FOR C. CONTRACTS AND
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL IS
REQUESTING TO EXTEND THE
LIQUIDATION TERM FROM JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. HE'S NOT TIME TO REACH TO
TARGET POPULATIONS AND EXHAUST
ALL FUNDS. IN ADDITION FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SEAT
AWARDEES WERE ISSUED TO YOUR
CONTRACT TERMS IN THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PLAN ALL. PLANS TO
IMPLEMENT THIS IS A STANDARD
PRACTICE FOR ANY FUTURE SEED
CONTRACTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU WE ARE GONNA GO TO
DEPARTMENT I'M SORRY THE L. A-
PLEASE. HELLO AGAIN WE HAVE NO
COMMENT FROM THE SENATE. THANK
YOU ADD A PART OF FINANCE.
BETTER TOUGHEN DEPARTMENT PLANS
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THE AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CREATED A
JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS CAN
EIGHTY P. CLARIFY HOW MUCH
FUNDING GOES GOES HAS GONE OUT.
A YES I HAVE- NUMBERS FOR THEM
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ONE THREE
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS MY
MOST CURRENT NUMBERS. UGH
CURRENTLY FOR GRANT INVOICING WE
HAVE DISTRIBUTED- A LITTLE OVER
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION. AND HOW
MANY ORGANIZATIONS HAVE RECEIVED
THE FUNDING AND APPROXIMATELY
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS A BENEFIT
FROM THE PROGRAM. ARE THERE ARE
NINE ORGANIZATIONS- WHO HAVE-
WERE AWARDED FUNDING. AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS- SO THEY'RE GONNA
ISSUE MICROGRAMS SO TOTAL
MICROGRAMS DISPERSED IS SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR. THANK
YOU APPRECIATED IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN THANK YOU. WE ARE
MOVING FORWARD THE FINAL LABOR
ISSUE IS THE ELECTRONIC
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION. TRY TO SAY THAT
FIVE TIMES FAST. WILL BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. Q. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM PAGE LEVY CHIEF
JUDGE FOR THE DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT OUR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR UPGRADING OUR
ELECTRONIC EDUCATION MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM OR TEAMS. WHICH WILL
SUPPORT THE WC CLAIMS
ADJUDICATION UNIT IN HEARING
ABOUT AGING CASES THAT ARISE
OVER DISPUTES FOR INJURED
WORKERS BENEFITS CLAIMS. IT WILL
ALSO ALLOW D. W. C. TO BETTER
ADJUST TO THE LEGISLATIVE AND
REGULATORY CHANGES WITHIN THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM AS
WELL AS BETTER TRACK IN DATA IN
IT. CHRIS COMPENSATION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE REGULATION
AND OVERSIGHT OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS THE WCW
DASCHLE SERVICES TO RESOLVE
WORKERS COMPENSATION DISPUTES
THAT ARISE IN CONNECTION WITH
CLAIMS FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS. EAMS IS THE ELECTRONIC
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT
ALLOWS THE D. W. C. TO SCHEDULE
HEARINGS PROCESS DOCUMENTS AND
ASSIST WITH CASE MANAGEMENT FOR
THE DIVISION. AMES CURRENTLY
SUPPORTS ROUGHLY SEVEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION CASES. TO BE ABLE
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
DIVISION THE W. C. IS CURRENTLY
WORKING TO REPLACE THE SYSTEM.
THIS RESEARCH REPLACEMENT IS
ESSENTIAL TO MAKE SURE D. W. C.
MAY CONTINUE TO FULFILL ITS
MISSION TO LESSEN THE IMPACT OF
WORK RELATED INJURY. EMPLOYER D.
W. C. IS WORKING CLOSELY CLOSELY
WITH ITS OFFICE OF INFORMATION
SERVICES AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY ON THIS
PROJECT WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
S. TO A PHASE OF THE CD T.
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
PROCESS. AS MENTIONED IN THE
COMMITTEE AND ASSISTED THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR SIX
POSITIONS AN ASSOCIATED
OPERATING EXPENSES INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR BUSINESS. AND DATA
ANALYST CONSOLE. SO FUNDING WILL
ALLOWD. W. C. TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS IN WHAT IS EXPECTED TO
BE A MULTI YEAR PROJECT WITH
THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE
YOUR- YOU WERE GOING TO GO TO
THE L. L. DAHLE DALY- WE HAVE NO
COMMENT ON THIS PROPOSAL. THE
PERMANENT. THE TOP IN THE FROM
THE FINANCE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME WOULD HAVE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
IS A LUMINARY ESTIMATED PROJECT
COSTS AVAILABLE. I AM I BELIEVE
OUR CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER
BEN BONTA IS IN THE ROOM I'M
GOING TO DEFER THAT QUESTION TO
MR BONTA. EMBODIED CIO ED D. I.
R. ARMY AS DOES LEVY ALLUDED TO
WE ARE IN STAGE TWO OF THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE- SO
ARE ESTIMATES ARE PRELIMINARY WE
DID SUBMITTED ASTON. HUNDRED
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
STAGE. THE STOCK. AND DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION PLAN ON
SUBMITTING A SEPARATE PROPOSAL
ON A LATER DATE FOR THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SYSTEM AND
SOFTWARE CHANGING OF SO WHEN.
I'M AB PAGE LEVY AB DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION YES WE DO-
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ET AND
GOING THROUGH THE POWER PROP US
AS SOON AS WE HAVE THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION GATHERED AND THE
PROCESS IS COMPLETE WE WILL
SUBMIT AN- WE ARE. A SLOW AT.
ROUTE PROCESS AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT ADDITIONAL PROPOSAL WILL BE
SUBMITTED FOR NEXT YEAR. NO
ADDITIONAL OUR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD AND HOLD THIS ITEM- OPEN
FOR THE MOMENT THANK YOU. UP
WE'RE GONNA ADD ON A MEMBER
RIGHT NOW TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. ME JUST A MOMENT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE FIRST MOTION
IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE FOLLOWING
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR ISSUES ISSUES
ONE THREE ELEVEN FIFTEEN THROUGH
1-793-242-6240 TO FORTY SIX TO.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY FIFTY FOUR
COOPER. I IN. HI. WE'RE GOING TO
DO A TWO OTHER BATCHES. THE
SECOND MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY ISSUE ON THE
ONE ON THE CALENDAR ISSUE TWELVE
THROUGH FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE AND
FIFTY TWO COOPER. COOPER I.
THEY'RE IN HIGH. THE THIRD
MOTION ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR
IS TO ADOPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EIGHTEEN.
FORTY THREE FOUR THROUGH FORTY
FIVE. COOPER COOPER HI THERE IN
THIS AREA HI. ON THE ITEMS TO BE
HEARD ISSUE NUMBER TWO SALES AND
USE TAX EXCLUSION. NAZARIAN THE
VERY ANTI. ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THE MOTION IS TO OUR THIRD OF
THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT SPRING
FINANCE LETTERS FOR ISSUE NUMBER
THREE AND IT'S MANIFESTING
CONSIDERATIONS AND SPENT.
NAZARIAN IS THERE A. THE NEXT IS
A MOTION TO ADOPT THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER FOR ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR I T. WORKLOAD SUPPORT. NEXT
IS A MOTION TO ADOPT SPRING
FINANCE LETTERS FOR ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE TWENTY EIGHTEEN COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT
MITIGATION PROGRAM. THIS AREA.
IS THAT IN HIGH. FINAL MOTION IS
TO ADOPT SPRING FINANCE LETTERS
FOR ISSUE NUMBER NINE LEGAL
WORKLOAD GROWTH IS THERE IN.
THERE IN. THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
KEEP MOVING FORWARD THE- NEXT
ITEM IS ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
SACKER YES EXPOSITION PARK. YES
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN EXPOSITION
PARK SPRING FINANCE LETTERS.
LET'S HAVE OUR PANELISTS PRESENT
ON THE THREE PROPOSALS THE
SOUTHEAST PARKING STRUCTURE
STUDY THE PARK WIDE SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEM AT BASELINE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FOR MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIRS BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS VANESSA AS
FAR AS THAT IN THE END FROM
GENERAL MANAGER WITH OFFICE
AFFECT TO THE MINUTE. SO BINANCE
BEFORE YOU THESE STRUCTURES TO
THE OFFICE OF EXPOSITION MANAGED
REQUEST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
OF COST ESTIMATES THE- ABILITY
TO COME FROM PARKING STRUCTURE
WITH THE FESTIVAL OF THE PARK
JACK IS YOUR- YOU. ARE A PART.
UNDERGROUND STRUCTURE WILL BE
TOPPED OFF FOURTEEN ACRES TO BE
BY WHAT CAN PARKS VISITORS HELLO
SIR AS THE REVENUE SPACE. ON TO
THE SECOND ITEM WHICH IS THE
PARK RIGHT SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM.
OF THE OFFICE OF EXPOSITION PARK
MANAGEMENT SEEKS THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT A PARK WIDE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM. THAT WILL.
WORK PUBLIC SAFETY COULD.
THROUGH DEGREE LIABILITY TO THE
STATE FOR LOSS OF PROPERTY IN
LIFE AND ALLOW FOR MORE
PROACTIVE POLICING TO PROTECT
THE STATE ASSETS AND THAT. THE
STUDY EVEN COME. AT A STUDY
ALREADY BEEN. OF THE NEXT STAGE
OF THE PROJECT WOULD BE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PRELIMINARY PLANS
WHICH THE JOHN DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATED WILL
COST. APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. THE
THIRD. IS THE BASELINE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FOR MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR. THE OFFICE OF EXPOSITION
PARK MANAGEMENT REQUEST FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO ACQUIRE GOODS AND
SERVICES INCLUDING BRING
UTILITIES AND OPERATION IRAQI
WHICH WORK. THE MAINTENANCE OF.
THE END OF NARRATIVE. TO
RESTORE- UPM'S OF LOS PARKING
DUE TO COULD. OF THE MUSEUM.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD BE ADDING
ONE ADDITIONAL ASSOCIATE
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM ANALYST- HEPA
TO SUPPORT WITH ADDITIONAL WORK
WHAT KIND OF CLIENT GOODS AND
SERVICES. FOR THE MAINTENANCE OF
THE FUTURE. THANK IT WILL OPEN
IT UP TO QUESTIONS THANK YOU
LET'S HEAR FROM IOP. I NEED ONLY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE NO CONCERNS OF THESE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE GOOD
AFTERNOON MIKE MCGINNIS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU I HAD I DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS- RELATED TO WHAT
WAS DISCUSSED WHAT IS THE
CURRENT OCCUPANCY RATE FOR THE
EXISTING PARKING INFRASTRUCTURE
STRUCTURE HAS THE PARK.
EXPERIENCE CAPACITY ISSUES IN
THE PAST. SURE SO THE PARK
EXPERIENCES SURGES SO- THE
PRIMARY USE OF THOSE PARKING
AREAS IS TO ACCOMMODATE AND
RESPOND TO SPECIAL EVENTS-
CURRENTLY WE USE THAT SPACE NOT
A HUNDRED. PER CALENDAR YEAR OF
OBVIOUSLY THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WITH KOPET HAS CHANGED
GREATLY. ON WE HAVE A 7%
OCCUPANCY RATE FOR THAT AREA
WHICH- SEVERAL. RELIES ON A
DAILY BASIS- IN REGARD TO YOUR
SECOND QUESTION ABOUT CAPACITY
ISSUES SO- EXPOSITION PARK IS
HOME TO TWO MAJOR STADIUM BANK
OF CALIFORNIA STADIUM AS WELL
THE COLISEUM. AT ANY GIVEN TIME
WHEN THEY DO HOSTED BANDS- WE DO
REACH CAPACITY ACROSS THE PARK
AND WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE ALL PARKING NEEDS-
AND THOSE TO GET USED TO FULL
CAPACITY DURING THOSE MAJOR
EVENTS. AND WILL THE STATE THAT
YOU MAY CONSIDER ANY OTHER
ALTERNATIVES OTHER THAN AN
UNDERGROUND PARKING STRUCTURE.
THE STUDY WILL NOT CONSIDER
OTHER ALTERNATIVES- AT AS AS IT
RELATES TO ABOUT PARKING
STRUCTURE ON A POLICY OF THIS
THIS UNDERGROUND PARKING
STRUCTURE WHAT'S THAT AND QUOTED
INDEED EXPOSITION PARK MASTER
PLAN. WHICH WAS DEVELOPED AND
SUPPORTED BY THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
PARKS STAKEHOLDERS- AND THAT
IDEA OF AN UNDERGROUND PARKING
STRUCTURE WOULD MAXIMIZE THE USE
AND PROVIDES. HERNANDEZ. THANK
YOU FOR THAT I WENT TO USC SOME
VERY FAMILIAR- WITH THAT
LOCATION IN THE PARKING
DIFFERENT MUSEUMS AND THE NEW
STADIUM AND ALL OF THAT AND YOU
KNOW ONE THING THAT COMES TO
MIND BEING FROM LOS ANGELES IS
JUST WE WANT TO RELY ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. BUT IT JUST
ISN'T THERE AS QUICK WE WILL
LIKE IT AND SO LA IS STILL VERY
CAR CULTURE CITY UNTIL YOU KNOW
WE HAVE- MORE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
ARE VASTLY ME. FOR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SUCH. IT THAT
THIS GOING TO SOME GENERAL
QUESTIONS FOR YOU WHY IS THE
CITY WHY IS A STUDY OR THE
PARKWAY SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM
PROPOSED TO BE FUNDED BY THE
GENERAL FUND INSTEAD OF THE
EXPOSITION PARK IMPROVEMENT
FUND. THESE PROPOSALS BE
APPROVED WHAT IS THE ANTICIPATED
REQUESTED SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
CONSTRUCTION. OR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THESE PROJECTS. SURE SO FOR
THE UNDERGROUND PARKING
STRUCTURE- SARZAMEEN MAY GO BACK
TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION IN TERMS
OF THE FUNDING SOURCES SO THE
EPRDF WHICH IS A SPECIAL FUNDS
IS UNSUPPORTED PRIMARILY FROM
PARKING REVENUE- OFFENSE LEAST
REVENUE WILL. RENTAL RENT
REVENUES AND EXPECTATIONS-
WITHIN THE PARK- OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS WITH THE STATE OR
MORTARBOARD ORDERS SB CLOSURES
AT THE MUSEUM- AND EVENTS. OF
THE EPA EFE HAS HAS ESSENTIALLY
BEEN ESTIMATED- AND WENT FROM
COLLECTING A BALANCE OF NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION TO ABOUT
PROXIMITY FOUR MILLION OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS. AND SO AT THIS
MOMENT- THE EPF WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO SUSTAIN THESE THESE.
REQUESTS THE TERMS OF THE
CONSTRUCTION COST THIS. WOULD. A
NUMBER FOR. CALLS AT THAT TIME
WE WOULD- INVESTIGATE ALL
POSSIBLE. FUNDING SOURCES
INCLUDING FEDERAL- LORS AND-
GENERAL FUND- BOND- MEASURE
BORDER. OVER THOSE.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA MOVE ONTO
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN THE ARTS
COUNCIL. WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL SPRING
FINANCE LETTER LET'S BEGIN.
HELLO HI. HELLO CHAIR CARILLO
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOPER
LACKING IS ERIN AND WICKS ON MY
NAME IS JONATHAN MOSCONI AND I
AM THE NEW APPOINTED DIRECTOR OF
THE ARTS SO. I'LL TRY TO BE
BRIEF IN MY THIRTY FIVE YEARS AS
AN ARTS PRACTITIONER I'VE GONE
FROM MAKING ART TO MAKING IT
POSSIBLE FOR OTHERS TO MAKE ART
AND I TAKE THAT COMMITMENT TO MY
NEW ROLE. TO SUPPORT AS MANY
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE AND AS
EQUITABLY AS POSSIBLE. I AM
BRAND NEW TO THIS JOB AND I HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO. AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO BE VIRTUALLY HERE
WITH OUR DIRECTOR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AYE JANAKPURI. AND
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
PRESSED MARGOLIS TO TALK IN
DETAIL ABOUT THE TWO AGENDA
ITEMS CULTURAL DISTRICTS AND
REAPPROPRIATION. FOR ME RIGHT
NOW I KNOW THAT I MUST START MY
JOB IS LISTENING. AND TO THAT
END I WILL BE SPENDING THE NEXT
NINETY DAYS. GOING ACROSS THE
STATE TO LISTEN TO EVERYONE SO I
HAVE THE BEST CHANCE INSURING
THAT OUR WORK REFLECTS THE
VOICES OF STAKEHOLDERS.
LISTENING AND COMMUNICATING. AND
THIS STARTS AT HOME WITH OUR
HARD WORKING STAFF. OUR COUNCIL
THE LEGISLATURE YOU
MINISTRATION. ALL THE FOLKS
DOING THE GREAT WORK THROUGHOUT
THIS. IN RURAL SUBURBAN AND
URBAN LOCATIONS SUCH AS CULTURAL
DISTRICTS. WHERE THE FOCUS OF A
THIRTY MONTH MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION. PUT FORTH BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR. MY KNOWLEDGE OF
CULTURAL DISTRICTS COMES FIRST
HAND FROM MY WORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALONG SIDE SOME UP
LOOKING US FILIPINO CULTURAL
HERITAGE DISTRICT. THIS
ORGANIZATION IS LED BY AND WORKS
WITH COMMUNITIES. THAT IN
HISTORICALLY EITHER THEY HAVE
TURNED IT INTO ONE OF THE MOST
VIBRANT CENTERS IN OUR CITY WITH
CULTURAL CELEBRATION COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE AT THE COURT IN
PRACTICE THEY LIKE THE FOURTEEN
DESIGNATED GEOGRAPHICALLY AND
RACIALLY DIVERSE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS AS WELL AS THE MANY
NON DESIGNATED CULTURAL. AND YOU
SO MUCH WITH SO LITTLE FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES OUR COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S ALL WE NEED TO DO I
BELIEVE IS TO INVEST MORE DEEPLY
IN THEM. STRENGTH AND THEIR
IMPACT SUSTAIN THRIVING
RESILIENT BUSINESSES INCREASED
TOURISM AND OPPOSE THE CULTURES
THAT MAKE CALIFORNIA A GENUINELY
GREAT STATE. AND THAT INCLUDES
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS THE LOT NEXT
COMMUNITY IN THE FIFTY FIRST
DISTRICT. THE CHINESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY THE NINETEENTH
DISTRICT THE AMERICAN INDIAN
CULTURAL DISTRICT AND INDEED
PRIORITIZING AS MANY AS POSSIBLE
THE DISTRICTS REPRESENTING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WITHIN
UNDER RESOURCE YEAH ARE AMONG
THE GREATEST ASSETS IN
REBUILDING A BETTER CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL. HOW DO I KNOW WE CAN DO
THIS SUCCESSFULLY AND IN GUARD
ENGAGE IN START THESE
COMMUNITIES THE CDC HAS PROVEN
TRACK RECORD WITH ITS PROGRAMS
SUCH AS CULTURE OUTWEIGHS WOULD
STRENGTHEN. CASSIDY A SMALL NEW
AND EMERGING ARTS ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE ROOTED IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR RECENT IMMIGRANT RECIPE
REFUGEE COMMUNITIES AND TRIBAL
AND INDIGENOUS GROUPS. ARTS IN
CORRECTIONS. A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AND THE ARTS COUNCIL THAT HAS A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING THE TRAUMA OF
INCARCERATION. AND PROMOTING
HEALING AND INTERPERSONAL
TRANSFORMATION BOTH INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE. MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
ARTS COUNCIL PRACTICES JUST AND
EQUITABLE DISBURSEMENT OF
RESOURCES OUR POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS ARE CREATED AND
ADMINISTERED TO IDENTIFY AND
AVOID DISCRIMINATION AND
BARRIERS TO ACCESS TO FUNDING.
AND TO AVOID DESPITE. THE HIGH
AND ADVERSE EFFECTS COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR THIS IS ABOUT OR
PRACTICE. AND OUR BELIEF.
FINALLY I KNOW THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT REPORT WE
APPROPRIATION OF MONEY AND
SPECIFICALLY CAN WE MANAGE THESE
BONDS. AND GET THEM OUT THE DOOR
. MY COLLEAGUE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
IONIC BRIEFLY TALK MORE ABOUT
THE RE APPROPRIATION OF FUNDS
AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE AND ARE
IMPLEMENTING SYSTEM TWICE AND
STOP HIRING. ASSEMBLY DISPERSED
THIS MONEY THAT REPORTED. BUT I
BELIEVE THAT THE ARTS COUNCIL
DOES HAVE THE CAPACITY TO ABSORB
THE PROPOSED WORKLOADS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WORKING
CULTURAL DISTRICTS WILL ALLOW US
TO HIRE A LIMITED STAFF PERSON
WILL CLOSELY WORK WITH ME AND
CALIFORNIA POET LAUREATE AND
YOUTH. PROGRAM ONE ABLE TO HIRE
A PERMANENT STAFF PERSON TO
SUPPORT THE USE DISBURSING OF
THESE FUNDS. AGAIN I KNOW I'M
NEW AND I HAVE A LOT TO LEARN.
BUT I KNOW THAT YOU'RE LISTENING
COMMUNICATING AND BUILDING
PARTNERSHIPS. I SO CAN MAKE GOOD
ON THE GOVERNOR'S AND MONUMENT
TO GET MONEY AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND IS BACK WITH. US OF COURSE
THE ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MOSCONI AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
THE NEW POSITION WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU. THE TIER
FROM THE L. A. L. OF FIRST. YES
COMPUTERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED RE APPROPRIATION- BUT
SIMILAR TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE NOTED BY YOUR STAFF IN THE
AGENDA. IT DOES RAISE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ARTS
COUNCIL'S ABILITY TO GET THESE
GRANT DOLLARS OUT AND THE IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS. THE COUNCIL HAS
BEEN PROVIDED PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
ONE TIME INFUSIONS OF GRANT
FUNDS. AND THE N. AT THE ARTS
COUNCIL CAN BE KIND OF FEAST OR
FAMINE DEPENDING ON THE STATE'S
BUDGET CONDITION THAT. SO
THEY'VE HAD BASIC CAN'T ONE TIME
INFUSIONS AS WAS MENTIONED- AND
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION
pFINDS AND OTHER PROPOSED- NOT I
DON'T THINK ON THIS AGENDA BUT
REFERENCED AND- FOR NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET FOR THE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROGRAM AND SO IT JUST
RAISES SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT DOES
THE ARTS COUNCIL HAVE THE
RESOURCES. NECESSARY I BELIEVE
THAT DIRECTOR MENTIONED THAT
THERE WOULD BE- MAYBE STAFF
POSITIONS THAT GO ALONG AT THE
CULTURAL DISTRICTS PROPOSAL IS-
APPROVED. I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
THAT ONE IN FRONT OF ME BECAUSE
THAT ONE'S NOT ON YOUR AGENDA
TODAY BUT I DON'T RECALL THAT
BEING PART OF THE PROPOSAL AND%
SAID THAT MIGHT JUST BE
SOMETHING. FOR THE COMMITTEE TO.
TAKE THESE AS UNDER
CONSIDERATION AS A- IT'S ONE
TIME. THEY HAVE A CLOSE ON REESE
AND IS THAT PHYSICIANS REALLY
INCLUDE IN THE PROPOSAL AND
PERHAPS FINANCE CAN WEIGH IN ON
THAT. THANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATED
APARNA FINANCE. HI TIM WEBER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I CAN
CLARIFY THAT POINT- THE COLLEGE
BOWL HAS UP 21% ABLE FOR ADMIN
SAID ARTS COUNCIL APPOINTED
MINISTER THE ESTABLISH A
POSITION. BUT I THINK I'M SORRY
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT. YEAH THE
PROPOSAL HAS UP 21% AVAILABLE
FOR ADMIN COSTS FOR THE ARTS
COUNCIL AS FOR THE- BUDGET
PROPOSAL. IS ANTICIPATED
ESTABLISH A POSITION NOT IS NOT
ACTUAL POSITIONS WITH US. ALSO
THAT MAKES SENSE. AND I THINK
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME JUST SOME
UNDERSTANDING YOU THROUGH YOUR
MASK MY APOLOGIES DO QUICKLY
SAID HELLO- THE DISTRICT
PROPOSAL AS UP 21% AVAILABLE FOR
ADMIN COSTS IN SO THE ARTS
COUNCIL PLANNING TO WITH THAT UP
21% HIGHER A PERSON WITH IMAGE
OF ESTABLISHED. I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE DIRECTORS MENTION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND. YEAH
I JUST I AM- FOR THE COMMITTEE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION CANNOT
ESTABLISH BECAUSE- THAT ARE
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
USING THIS PROCESS TO
ADMINISTRATIVELY ESTABLISHED
POSITIONS. BUT TO THE EXTENT
THAT. IT'S KNOWN THAT THOSE
POSITIONS ARE NEEDED TO GO WITH
THE PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE YOU.
AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WAY AND ON. WHAT
WHAT SORT OF SUPPORT IS NEEDED
AND WHAT TYPE OF POSITION AND
HOW MUCH AND CLASSIFICATIONS AND
ALL THAT. YOU DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO DEFER ABOUT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THE WAY THAT THE
PRO PROPOSAL IS CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED. AGAIN THAT'S
ACTUALLY A- ONE OF MY FOLLOW UP
QUESTION SO MUCH APPRECIATED
DEPART OF FINANCE THAT YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD ON THE
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATED. THAT'S MISTER IS
GONNA YOU MENTIONED THAT-
SOMEONE ON YOUR ON YOUR TEAM I
BELIEVE- MISTER BERRY WAS ABLE
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS RELATED
TO STAFF. SO GIVEN THE POTENTIAL
INVESTMENT. ON THIS PROPOSAL.
THEREIS CONCERN AS YOU'VE HEARD
IN THE CONVERSATION ABOUT- THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO ADMINISTER
SUCH A LARGE SCALE PROGRAM. SO
CAN YOU SPEAK ON THAT. AMOUNT OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN. I AND I
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO TAKE UP
ARMS SURE YEAH I THINK WHAT-
WHAT I'M DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES.
IS SHARED IS WHAT WE HOPE TO
HAPPEN IS THAT WITH THE WITH THE
ADDITIONAL OR WITH THE ABILITY
TO TAKE 1% OF THE FUNDS. OR
CULTURAL DISTRICTS TO ESTABLISH
A POSITION WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A MANAGER POSITION- IN
ORDER TO MANAGE OVER FOUR GRAND
AND WE HAVE. VERY MAKING SOME.
THIS TO RUN OUR REGULAR GRANT
PROGRAMS AND THAT MANAGER WOULD
BE ABLE TO AND WE CAN GET SOME
LIMITED TERM AGING HERE IS THAT
WOULD BE DOING THE PROGRAM AND
THAT MANAGER WOULD BE HELPING TO
. HOPE OVERSEE CULTURAL
DISTRICT. I FEEL LIKE WITH OUR
CURRENT STAFFING PLAN ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE WE ARE FILLING MORE
VACANCIES AND BUILDING A
RESTORING OUR CAPACITY TO RUN
OUR REGULAR GRANT PROGRAMS AND
PROGRAMS THAT ARE COMING UP.
ESPECIALLY WITH THAT 1% WE WOULD
BE FINE. THANK YOU APPRECIATED-
I KNOW THAT THIS S A
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD IN
PREVIOUS HEARINGS AND- AS WE
WELCOME MR MOSCONI AND HIS
LISTENING TOUR ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THE RECOMMENDED
PERHAPS TO THE PREVIOUS HEARINGS
WERE WE WENT QUITE INTO SOME
DEPTH OVER THIS. IN ADDITION. OF
STAFF NOTED THERE HAVE BEEN NO
EXPENDITURES FOR SOME OF THESE
FUNDS HAS SINCE THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY APPROPRIATED. COULD-
THE C. A. C. EXPLAIN WHY THESE
LOCAL. PROGRAMS DOLLARS HAVEN'T
OPENED. YEAH I CAN TAKE THAT IF
THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO THE- IN TWENTY TWENTY
JUST TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND THE CCNP ANTICIPATED
THAT DUTY GRANT PROCESSING
DELAYS. AND IMPACT YOUR GRANT
APPLICATION ORGANIZATIONS WE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO ENCUMBER
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT INCLUDED TWO
SPECIAL FUNDS ARE ARTS LICENSE
PLATE ZERO ZERO SEVEN EIGHT AND
ARE A KEY PART BECAUSE SCHOOLS
FUNDS WHICH ARE BOTH FUNDS THAT
WE DON'T NECESSARILY COUNT ON
EVERY MONTH BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW THOSE ARE REVENUES THAT
COME AND- WE'RE NOT ALWAYS ABLE
TO ANTICIPATE WHAT THOSE
REVENUES ARE SO WE GENERALLY
TEND. TO LEAVE THE TOWARDS THE
END OF THE YEAR TO ACTUALLY
ENCUMBER AND EXPENSE BUT WHEN WE
REALIZED THAT WE WERE GOING TO
BE THERE BECAUSE OF THE LABOR
GOING TO HAVE THIS MONEY ON THE
TABLE WE DID ASK FOR A PC P. AND
AN EXTENSION OF OUR CUPBOARDS
PERIOD. WHILE WAITING FOR THAT
APPROVAL- THEY CAME A LITTLE BIT
LATER WE NEEDED TO START OPENING
OUR DOORS FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE GRANT SEASON AND STARTED
USING. TWENTY TWENTY ONE FUNDS.
BECAUSE GRANT. ONLY INTENT TO
USE ALL OF THE TWENTY OUR RECORD
TIME AND OF COURSE WITH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THERE WERE STILL SOME
DELAYS SO WE ARE PLANNING ON
SPENDING ALL OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE FUNDING IN
OUR CURRENT GRANT- PORTFOLIO
THAT TO FOURTEEN GRANT PROGRAMS-
THAT WILL BE ABOUT- SIXTEEN
WORKING GRANTS PROGRAM AND WE
WILL BE ABLE TO EXPAND ALL OF
THE FRIENDS AND SO ARE NEW AT
THIS PROPOSAL. IS TO ALLOW US
THE TIME TO GET ALL OF THOSE
INTO CONTRACTING COVER THOSE
FUNDS- AND THEN WE'RE ASKING FOR
EIGHT CONTINUOUS OR IN TWO YEARS
TO UNCOVER ALL OF OUR PLANS
MOVING FORWARD SINCE WE STARTED
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PRESIDENT BUSH SERVICES
WE FOUND THAT OTHER GRANT MAKING
AGENCIES AT THE STATE. WITH MORE
THAN ONE YEAR TO ENCUMBER THE
YEARS AND THAT IS WHAT IS THE
PROPOSED RIGHT NOW FEEL LIKE
THAT. WESENTLICH JUST TO HAVE IT
TO BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH SOME
IMPACTS EITHER- ANY CHANGES IN
THE IN OUR GRANT MAKING. I'M
TIMELINE THAT MIGHT IMPACT OUR
GRANT MAKING PROCESS. IT IS NOT
REALLY A MATTER OF CAPACITY IT'S
A MATTER OF HAVING THAT
FLEXIBILITY JUST LIKE OTHER
AGENCIES DO WITH THE STATE.
THAT'S ONE CHANGE WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO. AND THEN- WE WILL BE
LOOKING TO WE'RE RECRUITING ALL
OF OUR VACANCIES AND FILLING OUR
VACANCIES. AND SO WE FILLED
EIGHT VACANCIES SO FAR AND WE
ARE CONTINUING TO FILL ALL OF
THEM WE ARE- ADDING MORE STAFF
IN OUR OPERATIONS DEPARTMENT.
DEDICATED TO GRANTS MANAGEMENT
ACCOUNTING AND PROCUREMENT. AND
WE WILL BE LOOKING INTO A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION OF OUR
SPECIAL FUNDS THE LICENSE PLATE
FUNDS AND THE- AND KEEP RECORDS
SCHOOLS WE STARTED A
CONVERSATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WILL BE. MOVING TO
SECURE THAT IF THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY FOR US SO THAT WE'RE
NOT. IN THAT SITUATION AGAIN
WHERE WE. DON'T WHAT WE HAVE TO
EXCEED OUR INCUMBENTS. THANK YOU
MUCH APPRECIATED- AND ONE THING
THAT I WOULD NOT I THINK WE
DISCUSSED IN OUR LAST HEARING
WAS AN ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
TURN IN SOME OF THOSE. GRANT
AWARDEES OVER TO THE LEGISLATURE
SO THAT WE WOULD KNOW WHICH
PROGRAMS. WHICH ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN FUNDED LOCALLY NOT ON
A COUNTY LEVEL BUT MORE LOCALLY
SPECIFICALLY SPECIFICALLY TO
MEMBERS DISTRICTS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S STILL ON YOUR
RADAR. ABSOLUTELY OKAY. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE A AND
AGAIN MR MOSCONI WELCOME. TO
YOUR NEW POSITION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD. TO WORKING. I THINK FOR
THE INFORMATION THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD A THIS
ITEM OPEN FOR THE MOMENT THANK
YOU WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON. TO
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU FOR THIS ITEM- HERE
THREE ISSUES FOR THE SECRETARY
OF STATE CRUISING INCLUDED THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS. THAT'S
BECAUSE ELECTIONS. VOTER HOTLINE
STAFFING. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME FORWARD TO
DISCUSS THIS PROPOSAL MY NAME IS
JANET LEAN AND SHE FOR THE
ELECTIONS DIVISION FOR THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE. THE
SECRETARY OF STATE IS SEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND FOUR FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND GENERAL FUND
MONEY AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE ANNUALLY THERE AFTER. FOR
THE USE OF TEMPORARY STAFF TO
ASSIST WITH THE STATEWIDE
ELECTION VOTER SUPPORT ON THE
SOS. THE SECRETARY. LINE
SERVICES ONE OF THE SECRETARIES
PUBLIC FACING RESOURCES AND AS A
WAY FOR OFFICE TO CONVEY TRUSTED
INFORMATION TO VOTERS. AND SHE-
COULD STAFFING MAINTAINS A
SECOND. D. TO QUICKLY TRIAGE
DOCUMENT REPORT AND RESOLVE
ISSUES AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE TO
ENSURE ELECTION LAWS ARE
FOLLOWED AND THAT EVERY VOTER
HAS THE ASSISTANCE THEY NEED. TO
EXERCISE THE RIGHT TO VOTE THE
SECRETARY STATE HAS HONEST A SAW
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN PHONE
CALLS AND REQUESTS FROM VOTERS
FROM THE TWO THOUSAND THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION WE SAW A HUGE
SURGE. IN THE LAST FEW ELECTIONS
WE'VE ALSO CHANSEN AN INCREASE
OF INTEREST IN ALL THINGS
ELECTION RELATED. SO AS THE
STATE FULLY TRANSITIONS TO AN
ALL ACTIVE VOTER OF ALL ACTIVE
VOTERS BEING MALE THEY'VE OPEN
MAIL BALLOT WE ANTICIPATE AN
EVEN LARGER NUMBER OF VOTERS
REACHING OUT TO OUR OFFICE FOR
INFORMATION AND EVEN EARLIER IN
THE ELECTION TIMELINE. SO A
GENERALLY THE CALL VOLUME- ARE
MOST OFTEN AFFECTED BY THE
INTEREST OF PARTICIPATION FOR
VOTERS. TYPICALLY PARTICIPATION
IS HIGHER DURING GENERAL
ELECTION YEARS. AND WE
ANTICIPATE THE INCREASE OF FOUR
OF A PARTICULAR BALLOT MEASURE
OR CANDIDATE ON THE BALLOT.
DRIVES PARTICULAR- NEED FOR OUR
OFFICE TO SUPPORT VOTERS THERE'S
A LOT OF DISCUSSION ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AS SOME FOLKS KNOW. AND
GOOD OR BAD A SOCIAL MEDIA THE
DISCUSSIONS PROVIDE A PROVIDE-
THAT VOTERS TO HAVE INTEREST IN
THE RESULTS IN COLOR OFFICE TO
ASK ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. IN
ADDITION WITH THE VOTING RULES
CHANGES AND METHODS CHANGE CALLS
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
THEIR FOR REQUESTING THIS
ADDITIONAL STAFFING FUNDING FOR
THIS TEMPORARY WORKERS TO HELP
ASSIST ON OUR VOTER ASSISTANCE
HOTLINE. THANK YOU. L. L. C.
FINANCE. IT AND WEBER PART OF
FINANCE NOTITIA COMMENTS LOL. WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS. QUICK QUESTION
HEALTH PANDEMIC IMPACTED VOLUME
OF CALLS TO THE VOTER HOTLINE AS
CALIFORNIA TRANSITIONS TO THE
ENDEMIC FACE NOW IS THIS
SECRETARY OF STATE AT
PROJECTIONS ON THE ANTICIPATED
VOLUME OF CALLS THE HOTLINE FOR
THE- NATION'S. D. A PANDEMIC WE
SAW A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
CALLS AS FOLKS ARE I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN KNOWING WHERE
THEY'RE VOTING OPPORTUNITIES ARE
AS WE TRANSITION TO ALL MAIL
BALLOT ELECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA
FOLKS REALLY WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
THEIR RIGHTS WERE AND SO THEY
WERE A LITTLE CONFUSED ON. WENTZ
AND SO DURING THE MID SEXUALLY
SAW QUITE A FEW QUITE A FEW A
SIGNIFICANT ACTUALLY INCREASE
AND CALLS. I BELIEVE AS WE
ANTICIPATE GOING INTO THIS NEXT
PHASE WE WILL STILL HAVE THESE
ANTICIPATED CALLS WE ANTICIPATE
SAID- RECEIVING SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF CALLS. BECAUSE WE'VE
TRANSITION TO AN ALL MAIL BALLOT
ELECTION WITH VOTING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS TO
UTILIZE AND SO WE ANTICIPATE
THAT IS STILL BE GREAT- I THINK
AS FOLKS KNOW ELECTIONS ARE NOT
A ONE TIME A YEAR OR TWO. THE
PROCESS EVERY IS INTERESTED ME
IN ELECTIONS AND THE OUTCOME AND
SO THEREFORE WE ANTICIPATE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF CALLS.
WHAT OTHER FACTORS DR CALL
WILLIAM. WHAT'S ON THE BALLOT
THE CONTEST SPECIFICALLY BALLOT
MEASURES AND OR CANDIDATESAND I
BELIEVE THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON WHEN WE
GET A HUGE VOLUME WHENEVER WE
GET A NEWS STORY WHENEVER
THERE'S A DEBATE. WHEN EVER
THERE IS OF ANY INTEREST IN
SOCIAL MEDIA IS WHEN WE SEE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN CALLS.
THANK YOU WHEN WILL THE NEXT
ISSUE WHICH IS VOTER CHOICE ACT
RESOURCES. PLEASE PROCEED. IT'S
ON NOW OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE THANK YOU
SO MUCH MONEY LOOKING AT JORDAN
I'M DEBBIE SECRETARY OF STATE
ADD THE POLICY AND PLANNING AND
OVER THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT SO
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
REQUEST FOR FUNDING OF THREE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR
OVERSIGHT ADMINISTRATION AND
VOTERS TWICE ACT IN CALIFORNIA.
OF THE BUSH WAS ACT WITH IN
POINT IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AT
THE TIME WHICH IS FIVE COUNTIES-
WE SAW IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT
NUMBER GROW TO FIFTEEN COUNTIES.
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE WILL
HAVE TWENTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA BOATING UNDER THIS
MODEL. WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT
WE HAVE HER. BORDERS LOCATIONS
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TEN DAYS
OF VOTING. AS WELL AS- BOOK BY
MAIL BALLOT BE MAILED WE ALSO
HAVE ABOUT THE PUBLICATIONS
BEING- AT THAT SET AROUND THE
WHOLE DIFFERENT- COUNTY. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE- MORE
OF BBM BALLOTS EMAIL BY DROP BOX
LOCATIONS. AND SO- THE PROGRAM
HAS GROWN FROM FIVE COUNTIES TO
TWENTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE A SIXTEEN MILLION VOTERS
VOTING UNDER THIS NEW MODEL- AND
SO IT'S- REALLY IMPERATIVE THAT
WE HAVE A MEANS OF HELPING
COUNTIES TO TRANSACTION AND
USHER IN THIS NEW EDUCATION
MODEL FOR VOTERS. I'M WITHOUT IT
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT I'M VOTERS
WOULD NOT BE AWARE OF ALL THEIR
OPTIONS FOR BOATING. AND SOME
MIGHT MISS OUT. THE QUITE
FRANKLY- WE START OFF WITH JUST
THREE POSITIONS- BACK INTO THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FOR FIVE
COUNTIES IF YOU COULD IMAGINE
THAT WITH TWENTY EIGHT COUNTIES
NOW WE WOULD NEED. SIGNIFICANT
MORE STAFF NOW WE'RE ONLY ASKING
FOR THREE TODAY BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT WE'VE BEEN STRETCHING AND
TRY TO MAKE IT WORK WITH SUCH AS
FAR AS WE COULD POSSIBLY GO.
POINT AND SO WE WOULD NEED TO DO
SOME POSITIONS. AND WEBER TO
FIND ITS NO ADDITIONAL. L. L. WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU. DOES THE SOS
ANTICIPATE ADDITIONAL COUNTIES
TO ADOPT THE VC MODEL IN THE
NEAR FUTURE. YES SO WE'RE ARE
CURRENTLY TRANSITIONING A TOTAL
OF THIRTEEN COUNTIES INTO THE
MODEL WHICH BRINGS US TO THE
TWENTY EIGHT- COUNTY TOTAL. AND
SO- WILL HAVE A TOTAL OF TWENTY
SEVEN- COME JUNE- ELECTIONS AND
THEN TWENTY EIGHT TOTAL COME THE
FALL A GENERAL ELECTION. AND SO-
SO YEAH I CAN'T SAY IT MORE AND
THEN I HAVE THAT. THESE
POSITIONS ARE GOING TO ACTUALLY
IMPROVE THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE PROGRAM AND HELP COUNTIES TO
DO THE OUTREACH EDUCATION THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING SADDAM OPEN AND ALSO
THE PREVIOUS ITEM OPEN. NEXT
WEEK FINAL ISSUE THE SEARCH
STATE. THIS CALL STEPHANIE THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON TOMORROW
JOHNSON CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS. A
PROPOSAL- THE FIFTIETH FISCAL
STAFFING PROPOSAL WHICH CONSISTS
OF SEVEN PERMANENT POSITIONS.
AND NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND NINE HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS- IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER. TO SUPPORT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S BUDGET
OPERATIONS. I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE HAS GROWN EXPONENTIALLY
OVER LAST WEEK. WITHOUT CREASES
TO STAFFING FOR THE BUDGETING
FUNCTIONS AND RECENTLY-
EVALUATION OF WORKLOAD AND
COMPLEXITIES THAT ACCOMPANY THE
TRIP ACCOMPANIED THE TRANSITION
TO FISKE OUT DETERMINED THAT
ADDITIONAL STAFFING IS NEEDED TO
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
COMPLETE THE BUDGET FUNCTIONS
AND MITIGATE ANY NEGATIVE
IMPACTS- TO THE AGENCY AND TO
THE STATE I REQUEST PROVIDE.
SERI TO SUFFICIENTLY STAFFED THE
BUDGET OFFICE TO COMPLETE BUDGET
BUILDING RESPONSIBILITIES AND
DUTIES RELATED TO EXPENDITURE
AND REVENUE TRACKING I'M TODAY
WITH ME REMOTELY I HAVE KRISTIN
BACK SURE AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE. AND WEBER
PROPONENTS NICKEL THOUGH NO
COMMENTS L. L. NOPE NO CONCERNS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
TRANSITION DEFENSE CAL HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING FOR SEVERAL STATE
DEPARTMENTS. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES IS THE SOS CONFIDENT
MISCIBILITY PROPOSED REPORTS ON
TIME. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- YES- WE HAVE RECEIVED
A RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO- ACCOUNTING AND PROCUREMENT
WITH PREVIOUS APPROVED PROPOSALS
ARE BY THIS- COMMITTEE AND SO WE
ARE CONFIDENT THAT THE ADDITION
OF THESE SEVEN STAFF POSITIONS
RELATED TO THE BUDGETING
FUNCTION WILL BE SUFFICIENT.
THANK YOU WERE HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN. THIS REMOTE ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN STATE COMPTROLLER.
WE WILL NOW HEAR ISSUES INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS THE STATE CONTROLLER
LET'S HAVE YES HE'LL PRESENT OF
BOTH THEIR ISSUES THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEES TELEWORK AND HEALTH
CARE STEP STIPENDS IMMEDIATELY
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
REPLACEMENT. GOTTA NUMEROUS
PANELISTS SO PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER URBAN I'M THE CHIEF OF
ACCOUNTING AND BUDGETS FOR THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
PRODUCES ALL CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYMENT RELATED PAYMENTS
WHICH EQUATE TO APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT POINT NINE MILLION PER
YEAR. AS HE WAS REQUESTING
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE
DISBURSEMENT OF TWO NEW PAYMENTS
ELIGIBLE TO STATE EMPLOYEES.
LIMITED TERM FUNDING IS
REQUESTED TO CONTINUE ONE
ADDITIONAL YOUR PAYMENTS FOR THE
PROGRAM TITLED IMPROVING
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. IN PERMANENT
FUNDING TO REQUEST. IMPERMANENT
FUNDING IS REQUESTED TO SUPPORT
THE RECENTLY NEGOTIATED TELEWORK
STIPEND PAYMENTS- ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS PROCESS SEPARATELY FROM
EMPLOYEE PAYROLL. THANK CHRIS
FUNDING WILL ALLOW SCO TO
PRODUCE AN ESTIMATED ONE POINT
ONE MILLION HEALTH BENEFIT
PAYMENTS AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
TELEWORK SECOND PAYMENTS
ANNUALLY ONGOING AND THIS
REPRESENTS THE POPULATION WITHIN
THE SIX BARGAINING UNITS HAVE
NEGOTIATED THE TELEWORK SECOND
TO DATE. THE REQUESTED RESOURCES
WILL SUPPORT THE PERSONNEL
RELATED COST FOR THE END TO END
CLAIM TO PAYMENT PROCESSING. FOR
ALL PAYMENTS AS WELL AS THE HARD
COSTS INCLUDING THE PAPER
MACHINERY AND SUPPLIES TO
PRODUCE THE PAPER WARRANTS. THE
SECOND ITEM UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY DIVISION IMPLEMENTED
THE UNCLAIMED PROPERTY SYSTEM OR
UPS TWO THOUSAND AS A SYSTEM TO
MANAGE UNCLAIMED PROPERTY THE
STATE RECEIVES FROM BUSINESSES.
SAFEGUARDS FOR OWNERS AND
RETURNS TO CLAIMANTS SUBS TWO
THOUSAND AND BY EXTENSION THE
COMPTROLLER'S UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
PROGRAM ARE AT RISK OF FAILURE
DUE TO THE SYSTEM'S OUTDATED
STATIC WHAT FORM AND THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND ABILITY TO COMMIT
ONGOING. DEVELOPMENT RESOURCES.
AS HE WAS REQUESTING RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT THE REPLACEMENT OF
UPS TWO THOUSAND WITH A NEW
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. ECOLOGY HAS ADVANCED.
SINCE THE UPS TWO THOUSAND WAS
IMPLEMENTED ALTHOUGH THERE HAS
BEEN ADDED FEATURES AND
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IN AN EFFORT TO KEEP IT
UP. THE ENHANCEMENTS OF
STRETCHED AND ONCE SO SIMPLISTIC
SYSTEM TO POINT WHERE ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS TAKE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE TIME AND MONEY. TO
IMPLEMENT. IN ADDITION EACH
AHEAD IN ENHANCEMENT FURTHER
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF SUCH
CRITICAL SYSTEM FAILURE.
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW SYSTEM WILL
NOT ONLY INCREASE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCY. BUT WILL RESULT IN
AN ESTIMATED NET INCREASE OF ONE
POINT- OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUES
TRANSFERRED TO THE GENERAL FUND.
AN ESTIMATED INCREASE OF FORTY
SIX MILLION IN UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY RETURNED TO OWNERS
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. BUT IT'S
- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SUSAN
WHAT KIND OF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT I WILL BRING WHETHER
FORD WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. I UNDERSTAND THIS
QUESTION MAY ALSO FALL UNDER
KELLY CHARGE STATION THE CEO OR
FINANCING DISSIPATE THAT THE
STATE'S WORKFORCE. LEFT
PERMANENT REMOTE WORK OPTIONS.
I'M SO GONNA KINDA THE OF
FINANCE THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT PILLOW
BECAUSE THE LONG TERM PERMANENT
STRATEGY. THE DECREASE OFFICE
SPACE ALLOW MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR
EMPLOYEES. RECRUIT AND RETRAIN
EMPLOYEES AS A COMPETITIVE
EMPLOYER AND PROVIDE RESILIENCE
IN CASTLE FUTURE EMERGENCIES.
OKAY THE RECOMMENDATIONS ALL
WITHOUT AN OPEN THREE HOLD OPEN
THANK YOU LADIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THIS SAYS MR
COOPER. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN VETERANS
AFFAIRS. THIS ISSUE WILL BE FOR
THE VETERANS DEPARTMENT OF
VETERAN AFFAIRS FOR THE YOUNG
WILL VETERAN HOME. THESE BEGIN.
I APOLOGIZE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BETH
MISSION TÌM ASSISTANT DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF VETERANS HOMES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS I HAVE WITH ME
ANDREW GELLER WHO IS WITH OUR
CHEAP ARE- FUTURE OPERATIONS AND
PLANNING UNITS OF ONE THING THAT
I MENTION ON THE AGENDA. LISTS
THOMAS MARTIN PRESENTING I AM
HERE IN THOMAS'S PLACE AS HE WAS
UNABLE TO ATTEND THIS AFTERNOON
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
FLEXIBILITY ON THAT. I'M CALVET
IS REQUESTING FIVE MILLION THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS THE UPGRADE ELECTRICAL
SYSTEMS- AT THE YACHT BILL
VETERANS HOME THIS PROJECT WILL
ALLOW FOR TEMPORARY EMERGENCY
POWER AT SEVEN RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS THAT DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE. THIS CAPABILITY. TELL THAT
WOULD USE FUNDING TO INSTALL
TRANSFER SWITCHES AND UPGRADE
ELECTRICAL PANELS WHICH ARE
NECESSARY TO CONNECT GENERATORS
FOR NOT FOR AN ALTERNATIVE POWER
SOURCE. IN THE EVENT OF POWER
OUTAGES. THERE'S GOOD FOR
RUNNING THE H. FAX SYSTEM
LIGHTING AIR PURIFIERS PERSONAL
MEDICAL DEVICES AND OTHER
ELECTRONICS AND EQUIPMENT IN
THAT BUILDINGS IN THOSE
BUILDINGS RELATED TO RESIDENT.
CARE AT PRESENT. ON THE PROPERTY
HAVE EMERGENCY POWER CONNECTIONS
WHICH LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCY POWER
OUTAGES AND ALSO MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO SHELTER IN PLACE.
WE FEEL THAT THIS PROJECT
STEPPED A CRITICAL STEP TOWARD
IMPROVING OUR EMERGENCY
IMPROVING OUR EMERGENCY PLANS
AND IF APPROVED IT WILL PROVIDE
US WITH ONE MORE TOOL TO KEEP
OUR VETERAN SAFE DURING FIRE
STORMS AND OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS WITH THAT WE WELCOME
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU LOL PLEASE. RUN WITH
THE FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DO NOT HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THIS ITEM. HE'LL
DEPART OF FINANCE. AND WEBER TO
REFINE ITS NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. THANK YOU- WE ARE I
HAVE SOME SOME COMMENTS ACTUALLY
SOME QUESTIONS HOW MANY POWER
FAILURES AS THE HOME EXPERIENCE
AND HAS A CALVET DESIGNED AND
IMPLEMENTED ADDITIONAL
CONTINGENCY PLANS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE RIVER.
IS A FUTURE ACCIDENTS. BY THE
ENTERED OUR WITH OUR ENTERED OUR
CALVET ACHILLES ANSWER THE FIRST
PART QUESTION- BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WITHOUT
DENTAL FIVE EIGHT POWER OUTAGES
AT THE HOME THAT IMPACTED THE
SEVEN BUILDINGS. AND I CAN SPEAK
TO THE SECOND PART OF IT YES
ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE- IMPROVED
UPON OUR- EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
CAPABILITIES I'M IN IN THAT
TIME- IN PARTICULAR WE'VE
IMPROVED UPON OUR- ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO MULTI FACETED. FOR
EXAMPLE WILL FIRE- DOESN'T IT IT
THREATENS PHYSICAL STRUCTURES
BUT IT DOES MORE THAN THAT IT'S-
A CAN WOULD RESULT IN- POOR AIR
QUALITY THAT IS- A CHALLENGE A
HEALTH CONCERN FOR. MANY OF OUR
RESIDENTS IT ALSO CAN CLOSE
ROADS- IMPACTING OUR STAFF'S
ABILITY TO GET TO WORK IT CAN
ALSO CHANGE. THE WAY THAT WE GET
SUPPLIES AND SUPPLIES YOU NEED
AND IT ALSO CHANGES THE WAY THAT
WE ARM CHANGES OUR OPERATIONS
SOMETIMES THE WITH THE WAY THAT
WE CARRY OUT OUR OPERATIONS- M.
AND SO THIS ACTUALLY. IS COME IS
A PART OF THAT SO FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE A- WE'VE MADE WE'VE MADE A
LOT OF CHANGES TO THE WAY THAT
WE- RESPOND- AT THE HEADQUARTERS
LEVEL. AS WELL AS IN THE HOMES
IN THE CONNECTIONS THAT WE HAVE
AND THEN ALSO OF COURSE WORKING
WITH CALLOW YES IN THE
CONNECTIONS THAT WE MAINTAIN
THERE. ARE WE HAVE AN EMERGENCY
COORDINATOR THAT WE'VE HIRED. TO
COORDINATE RESPONSE EFFORTS TO
ALL OF THIS- AND WE HAVE
DEVELOPED PROCEDURES AND- AND
PROTOCOLS AND THINGS OVER TIME
THAT YOU KNOW- AS WE'VE
EXPERIENCED THESE WE'VE BUILT.
THE SO IT. COOL TO ARM TO CARRY
THOSE OUT TO RESPOND TO THE
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT COME UP
THAT ARE PART OF OUR NORMAL
FUNCTIONS DURING THOSE EVENTS
AND THEN IT ALSO WOULDN'T IT
BETTER ENABLE US O SHELTER IN
PLACE WHICH OF COURSE IS ALWAYS
THE GOAL WHEN POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW
WE ARE VERY LIMIT. THIS ORDER TO
RESPOND TO BECAUSEOF THE SEVEN
BUILDINGS NOT HAVING A BACKUP
POWER SOURCE. THANK YOU AND HAS
CALVET DETERMINE THE PROPOSED
COST FOR THIS PROJECT. YES IS-
PARKING FIVE POINT THREE MILLION. AND HOW- HOW DID THAT NUMBER
COME ABOUT. AS SO GENERALLY
SPEAKING YOU KNOW LONG BEFORE-LEARNED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS OF THESE EMERGENCIES- AT
THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE OUR
WEAKNESS OF THE HOME THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE BACK UP OUR ANTI SEVEN
BUILDINGS OUT. AND SHOT TO AN
ENGINEERING FIRM TO DO A STUDY.
TO TRY TO DETERMINE EXACTLY HOW
TO ABOUT. THAT ACCESS TO- NO.
GENERATOR POWER WHENEVER THERE'S
ONE OF THESE EMERGENCIES WHEN
THE POWER IS OUT. THAT WE CAN
POSSIBLY SHELTER IN PLACE OUR
RESIDENTS- SO WE HAD A STUDY
DONE. AND THEY CAME BACK. WITH
THAT AND WE BASICALLY REACH OUT
THE DGS. WE WORK WITH UNDER
CENTER INTO. AN ESTIMATE BASED
OFF OF THE INITIAL STUDY IBM
ENGINEERING FIRM. AND USE OF A
TEMPORARY EMERGENCY- GENERATOR
POWER ALONG WITH THE HOME BE
SELF SUSTAINING DURING A POWER
FAILURE. GENERALLY SPEAKING- SO
LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO GET
ACCESS TO FUEL AS WELL AS
SUPPLIES LIKE FOOD OR WATER FOR
RESIDENTS- YOU KNOW THE IDEA
WOULD BE DOWNTURN OPERATE
INDEFINITELY- WE ALWAYS OF
COURSE. YOUR ORDER- SUPPLIES.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
AND LAST ISSUE IS ON THE
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION THIS
IS A REAL PLUS FOR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO BY THE CARDROOM
LICENSES LICENSING FEE
METHODOLOGY FOR THIS ITEM WE
LIKE OUR PANELISTS A CONTEXT AND
HISTORICAL OVERVIEW THE LEAD TO
THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE INCLUDING THE STATE
AUDITOR'S FINDINGS THE
COMMISSION SUBSEQUENT EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS. TRAILER BILL FEES
THE COMMITTEE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMISSION FOR
PROVIDING STAFF WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL INFORMATION ON THE
ISSUE IS AGAIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS STACY LETTER BAXTER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION TODAY I'M JOINED BY
OTHER.
PROVIDE A SHORT SUMMARY OF THE
REQUEST IN MAY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ORDER ISSUED AUDIT REPORT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ONE RETAIL. WITHIN THAT
REPORT THE AUDITOR SUCH
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE OF WHICH WAS
TO REQUIRE THE COMMISSION TO
ADJUST OUR FEET YOUR POSSIBLY
AND OFFICE EVERY. IN MEANT WITH
REGULATORY COSTS. PLEASE OF THE
ORDERS OR THE COMMISSION. LAUGH
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED EXPERTS OF
COST SERVICES ANNOUNCES AND FREE
REVENUE RECOVERY MDT CONSULTING
. TO CONDUCT A SENSE OF COST AND
FEE ANALYSIS AND PROPOSED THE
FEE RESTRUCTURING THIS WAS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BY NGT THE
PART OF THE JOB. TROLL ONCE IN
THE SYSTEM BE RESTRUCTURING
PROPOSAL WERE FINALIZED IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THEY WERE
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE STATE AUDITOR AND
WERE SUBSEQUENTLY APPROVED IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT
IS CONDUCTED CONFIRMS PROGRAM
ANNUAL UP AT ALL CURRENT. IF YOU
DOES NOT OUR WHAT THE TRIP BRAG
WITH COSTS. THE CA ALREADY FULL
REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO MODIFY
ALL BUT ONE OF ITS FEES THE CARD
ROOM ANNUAL FEE THE COMMISSION
HAS ALREADY LOWERED THOSE FEES
MARK FOR REDOX TO ZERO. US IS IN
THE FINAL STAGES THROUGH ITS
REGULATORY AUTHORITY TO ADJUST-ALL OTHER FEES EXCEPT FOR THE
CARD ROOM ANNUAL FEE AS IT IS
THE ONLY ONE THAT REQUIRE
STATUTORY AMENDMENT. THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
SEEKS TO ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO
MODIFY THE CARD ROOM ANNUAL FEES
THROUGH THE FORMAL REGULATORY
PROCESS. IT WAS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS APPROVED. THE
COMMISSION WELL AND MUST STILL
PROMULGATE THE CAP CARD ROOM
ANNUAL FEES VIA REGULAR TAKE
REGULATIONS. UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
AS SUCH THE REGULATIONS WILL
REQUIRE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
APPROVAL AND REVIEW AGAIN AS
WELL AS THE L. A. O.'S. AND
SIGNIFICANT UP SORRY THAT MR OF.
REYES AND SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR STAKEHOLDER
PARTICIPATION. WITHOUT APPROVAL
OF THE TRAILER BILL THE
COMMISSION WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION OR CHARGE THE
CARD ROOMS THE APPROPRIATE
ANNUAL THAT IS ALIGNMENT. TOWARD
FOR A COST. THE COMMISSION
PROVIDED THE SUBCOMMITTEE WITH
RESPONSES TO THE RECOMMENDED
QUESTIONS OUTLINED WE ARE HERE
TODAY RESPOND ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT THE THAT YOU MAY
HAVE AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU LET'S. I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE NO
CONCERNS THANK YOU THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON KEVIN CLARK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE. CENA
WE APPRECIATE WE APPRECIATE THAT
SOME OF THE ANSWERS THAT WE HAD
WERE ANSWERED AHEAD OF TIME- IN
WRITING SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
DOING THAT. WE ARE GOING TO.
RECOMMEND IS. AT KEEP OPEN SO WE
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE WILL NOW BE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC WILL POLICIES
WERE NOT CONCLUDING OUR HEARING
JUST YET WE ARE DONE WITH THE-
THE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION PANELS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY JUST GETTING- WE'RE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE-
HEARING ROOM OR ON THE PHONE THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CALL. SEVEN
SEVEN SIX. NINE FIVE SEVEN. THIS
CODE IS ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE
ONE ZERO ZERO. IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM. SEE
NON OPERATOR. THANK YOU. HE
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN AT
THE ONE. ZERO AND FIRST WE WILL
HEAR FROM LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTER A CAREER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS PETER COMISKEY REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS COALITION THEIR HOURS
YOU COULD FOURTEEN PILOT
CULTURAL DISTRICTS INCLUDING
EMERYVILLE LANCASTER YREKA HIGH
TWENTY FOUR IN SAINT PETE IN
LITTLE TOKYO. BOTH IN LOS
ANGELES JUST TO NAME A FEW.
PARTICIPATING WHAT GIVES
POTENTIAL PENCE BUT IF GRANT
FOCUSED ON DELIVERING SPECIFIC
AND- FOR THE- UNITIES. YOUR
CAPITAL DISTRICT OFFICES THIS
WEEK YOU SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED
COPIES OF THE LATEST COALITION
NEWSLETTER HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF
THE WORK BEING UNDERTAKEN BY
CULTURAL DISTRICTS AND RECOGNIZE
THE ENTHUSIASM SIX PROGRAM. POST
BUDGET CLEARLY. HE NEEDS TO GROW
THIS PROGRAM WITH SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITIES AS THERE ARE MANY
DISTRICTS THAT CURRENTLY AWAIT
CONSIDERATION FOR DISSIPATION.
YOU WANT TO SEE A DISTRICT
POLICE ABOUT THE BUDGET ITEM
WHEN IT IS RAISED ACTUALLY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
KNOW OUR CALLER PLEASE AND JUST
AS A REMINDER TO FOLKS THAT IT'S
A ONE MINUTE. PHONE TESTIMONY
PLEASE THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM LINE THIRTY SEVEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MONEY FACTOR FUNDING I AM THE
DISTRICT MANAGER OF THE BAR
LOGIN MAINTENANCE ASSESSMENT
DISTRICT I'M REQUESTING BOTH THE
CORE OF THE THIRTY MILLION
ALLOCATED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL PROVIDE ALL OF.
YOUR PROGRAM AS I FIVE BY
GOVERNOR YOU IN HIS PROPOSED
BUDGET I. PRODUCT IN THE THIRD
AND RACISM HAVE DEEP HISTORICAL
ROOTS IN A LOT. THE CULTURE
THIRD TO UNITE AND THREE
RESIDENT RT COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS
I'M- AND HAD DARK TRADITIONAL
COOK PRESERVATION OF NOT ONLY
CALLED HER OUT OUT THERE BUT THE
ARE THE WILD. THANK YOU AND WE
AGAIN REQUEST YOUR CALL SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU KNOW COLOR PLEASE. BLIND
TWENTY FIVE. HONORABLE CARE
CURIO AND MEMBERS THIS IS AB
HINDSIGHT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK WE ARE WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE COMMUNITY ANTI
DISPLACEMENT AND PRESERVATION
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD- I NEED A
BALL OUR COMMUNITY IS TO PRINTER
OR OF ALL. B. YOU CANNOT HEAR
CAN YOU SEND. WELL I AM THIRTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS PRIVILEGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES ON
ISSUE FIFTEEN OR RICH CAMPBELL
CAL POLY ARTS COUNCIL GRANTS ARE
CONSISTENTLY OVER PRESCRIBED
INCREASES FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR SECTOR
CULTURAL DESTRUCTION COULD BE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIA TOP LEFT CELEBRATE
AND RETAIN CULTURAL COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BUT ONLY IF IT
RECEIVES FUNDING WITHOUT IT.
VERIFIED THAT THE FUNDS THEY
MANDATE. FOR ME I. AND THE WILL
NOW GET YOU TO PROVE VALUE.
TODAY'S HEARING ANYTHING IS THAT
THE EIGHT. WE NEED MORE FUNDING
WITH IT WAS MORE A STAFF
POSITION LIKE MANY AGENCIES
STATE THEY HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR
A PERMANENT DOLLARS IN THE- IN.
I THINK IT QUITE SHOULD FILL IN
THE AN EXPEDITED TIME ESTIMATED
TIMELY MANNER YOU COULD BE UP TO
TODAY. LINE THIRTY FOUR. HELLO
AND GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS
LAUREN LANE AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE LANCASTER
MUSEUM OF PUBLIC ART ON WITH AND
PEOPLE OF ART CULTURAL DISTRICT
WHICH IS A MONTH THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT COALITION AS RECOGNIZED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
ON YOUR CULTURAL DISTRICT
HIGHLIGHT THE LEGACY OF
DIVERSITY WHICH IT WE- LARGER.
AREA A SHORT FOR A LOCATION EACH
TO HELP EMPATHY OFTEN ART AND
CULTURE OPPORTUNITY. INCREASE OF
THE GOOD OF LOW ARTISTS AND
PROMOTE A PROMOTE SOCIO ECONOMIC
AND ETHNIC DIVERSE. CULTURE AND
CREATIVE EXPRESSION. YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS THE FUTURE
BUDGET ITEM YOU. LINE THIRTY TWO
. A GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE- MAKING COMMENT
REGARDING GOVERNMENT MISSIONS
PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY MILLION
BUDGET FOR CULTURAL DISTRICTS TO
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL MY
NAME IS MARYLAND SOME OF
FILIPINO SAN FRANCISCO SPOKE NO
CULTURE OR TO DISTRICT. WE ARE
IN THIRTY ROCKEFELLER CULTURAL
DISTRICTS SANDIA ALTHOUGH SHE
RICA- ASKING- TO BE ALLOCATED
FOR CULTURAL BIT- CULTURAL
DISTRICTS IT SERVES AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN ADVOCATING FOR. RACIAL
AND ECONOMIC EQUITY IN OUR
CITIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND I
THINK- SOUNDING FOR INDEPENDENT
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES- HAVE THE
BEST LINK COLLATION SHIPS WITH
THE- THOSE THAT THAT NEED THIS-
THESE ARE RESOURCE MUCH AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
HAVE A GOOD DAY- LINE. THIRTY
EIGHT. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MECOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM EIGHT THE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT GRANT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET HOW
MUCH IT MEANT SENDING. AREAS
THAT. PEOPLE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY IS COOLER COUNTY IN THE
NAME PEPPERING OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES OUR
COMMUNITIES RANGE FROM URBAN TO
REMOTE HOMELESS CAMPS IN OUR
COUNTY ARE FREQUENTLY LESS THAN
FIFTY PEOPLE AND ARE FOUND IN
NON URBAN AREAS SUCH AS TRYING
TO PREVENT THE MOUNTAIN AREAS WE
HOPE THAT THE- YOU CAN'T MAKE
CLEARING. SPENDING WILL. US TO
ADDRESS OUR YOU KNOW HOME. BURKE
SAYS IN MORE URBAN OF THE STATE
THANK YOU. AND IT WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR MUCH
APPRECIATED WHEN I TAKE A MOMENT
TO THANK OUR BUDGET TEAM AS WELL
AS ALL OF OUR PANELISTS- IT WAS
THE L. A. O. AND MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE STAFF
BUDGET FOR HIM. IT IS A TURNED.